in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to a very special
episode of the genius man yes hailing
all the way from Canada we have yes
Russell formerly known as deep ride
which is crazy man because you know
what's interesting man now I've been
following you for a while right since
you were like super super young I found
actually found out about you through my
guys the stereotypes really yeah so they
were they were they were kind of scoping
around like young artists and talent
uh-huh so if you guys know the
stereotypes are you know you guys
probably know bland large legends right
legend just [ __ ] killing thumbs up to
them by the way session with them when I
was like 19 exactly so I mean it was a
dream come true like they were asking me
so I know John so John was asking like
you know have you heard of this kid deep
fried and I don't know who you were at
all at the time because I just wasn't
really on YouTube that much and for me I
just remembered that the music scene on
YouTube at that time anyways was like it
was all just covers right yeah nobody
was really doing original music yeah so
like for me I was just rather listen to
the original music at the time because
when people are doing covers they
weren't flipping it
ma were just trying to get like a really
cheap beat of it and then you know then
but then now that when that started to
evolve that's when I started getting
really into cover so I was like oh yo
these people are really putting new
spins on things mm-hmm when you switched
your name over to Russell I had no idea
where you went yeah that was kind of the
the aim I guess yeah more so because at
the time I knew I had a good little base
of people like a good little core base
of people that would follow me
throughout the transition yeah and then
I knew that I was dumping out a bunch of
fans that were kind of like halfway
there not saying that you were I'm sorry
just like where did he go yeah there
were I knew I had I knew I had a couple
and I won't say fickle because that just
seems so like aggressive but yeah I had
a couple half listeners a couple meaning
a lot and and rightfully so I mean I was
I was in the covers business per se you
know like yeah a lot of the cover fans
aren't really the most you know they
don't really show the most longevity
because they're there for that reason oh
yeah and I had a lot of fans and big
kudos to them that were there for the
sole purpose of like I I like this guy
no matter what he does yeah so I was
like okay maybe I'll do the name
transition along with these people and
take the hit on certain bookings that I
would get for being deep ride you know
what I mean like I guess my washed
bookings per se yeah I didn't want to do
those I felt like that would muddy my
name and I I'm I'm big on taste and I'm
big on brand for sure um but I'm also
big on brand not being forced I never
wanted it to be forced I felt like at a
certain point in time deep ride started
being forced hmm so that's why I was
like you know what I'm gonna take the
hit I'm gonna take the hit right now not
many views are gonna pop up at first not
many people are going to get it at
second and again people are gonna tell
me I'm stupid for three but at the end
of the day I really believe in what my
brand is and I really believe in myself
that's is so big movement that's kind of
right here for an artist you know yeah I
thought I really wanted to fight for
that I felt like I felt like I was more
than the YouTube cover kid
even when I first started I always felt
like I was bigger than that but it was
just not even not even degrading it at
all I'm just saying I I was able to get
out of that box that everybody kept
putting me in including the people that
you know gave me opportunities well yeah
I think it's because when when you start
off doing covers I think a lot of people
forget that you know you who are you as
an artist right because at that point
you're just taking somebody else's work
and then doing you know doing whatever
you want with
yeah and there's just like evolutionary
step that I don't think a lot of
youtubers took right there was a cover
band on YouTube they were an actual band
what the [ __ ] was their name but all
they did was covers do you know who they
are they there's a lot of them but they
would just make millions and millions
and millions of views only on their
covers book than when they would pop out
an original nobody would ever leave and
you know it was like there's like a
there's two sides to it right it's like
there's the fickle fan side but there's
also well you didn't develop yourself as
an artist so when yeah we got your
original music people are like what the
[ __ ] is this yeah yeah funny enough at a
certain point and all kudos to the label
that Simon before they really they were
really really with the vision of me
writing my own music I had always told
them like this is what I do I know and
they got it from the jump um so I just
thankfully I had a support system behind
me but I also do know the mistakes and
and the negative you know the negative
things that of course got attached to
that and that was like kind of you know
when I was a kid I always thought that
hits with the thing you always need a
kid you know and in the pop era that's
where you know at around the time I was
like I had to be 19 or 20 even before
that probably 17 or 18 just like in the
pop era that's what was making money
that was that's what was making moves
yeah now that's that's what was
mainstream and you know I got caught up
as a kid on being famous before I got
old you know and I think that's a big
problem with a lot of VAS dude you
popped off that yeah and I was almost
and I can't say that I don't want to
self-proclaim this so you know just you
know a little heads up on that but I
feel like I I was from what I hear at
least I I guess I was a pioneer of a
certain thing don't for sure um because
funny enough now I'm seeing more than
ever as the reinvented me that a lot of
people are much more appreciative of my
past and they tell me you know you were
that guy you were that guy that you know
you influenced me to buy my first
mic and write my first song yeah and do
XY and Z I felt like and I still feel
like if I if I really really ran the
cover thing I would have never
influenced a lot of people because the
covers were cool but it was like really
really making something out of myself
was my main goal I want to make
something out of myself I want my I want
it's write my own songs I want to put
them out and sorry and if I have you
know cover I'm gonna put my own thing to
it I don't want to sing the exact same
lyrics I want to always write my little
part yeah and I think that carried me I
think that carried me a lot you know
that that resilience to always at least
add my own thing to things and it's just
crazy I mean and circling back to what I
was saying before you know I feel it's a
big problem with not a big problem I'll
take that back but I feel it's somewhat
of a problem with the youth of today
yeah everybody thinks they need to get
lit when they're young and if you don't
get lit when you're young your time is
up
yeah not understanding like it's like
every corner yet Instagram post but
jay-z really did pop off at 26 yeah
there's there's fat yeah I mean there's
a fact about that like that you can read
about that you know mmm 26 like just
certainly a lot of artists a lot of
artists now you know that are at a
certain point that we can say okay that
[ __ ] got money you know that
[ __ ] made some moves they all
popped off later you know what I mean
and a lot of the a lot of the younger
artists that the had things come to them
so fast and it was lit and we saw
certain things like that they kind of
know all of them but majority of them
had a burn out you know or a burn out or
a psycho a lot mental burnout you know
what I mean we're sure because I don't
think I mean this is the hard thing for
people to understand it's like nobody
really is prepared for fame and stardom
right there's no glass there's no
etiquette on it you know that's why when
people were you know I would arguably I
was one of them too because it's already
funny and you start [ __ ] on somebody
like Justin Bieber right just because
yeah
but just in capsulated in something else
like do you know what it's like to be
given the world at the age of 15 dude
like insane it's it's a weird weird
experience everybody saying yes to them
there's not a single person that will
say no [ __ ] [ __ ] being thrown at you
I mean dude I still have some a light
amount of post-traumatic stress from
that I mean I go to therapy for it I
still sit there before it cuz you popped
off super [ __ ] young to just like
yeah man and it was there was a big life
how should I say this
I just there was a lot of adjustment I
had to do as a kid and I see it a lot
night I'd hate to I hate to relay it to
this or even relate it but you know it's
like a cat you know you take a cat and
you put it in a different place right
and it just moves it's kind of low to
the floor sometimes it's like where the
where the [ __ ] am i yeah you know what I
mean and when you put like you think of
like a 16 year old kid and you put them
in different situations he's like a
sponge you know what I mean like and
it's it's really hard at that age I feel
to adapt to so much when you're being
moved around a lot it's not a matter
we're not adults so it's like how can
you do this yeah and then imagine that
with you know people sucking your dick
everyday people feeding your ego and
then kids screaming for you and you know
do having to do meet-and-greets when you
don't feel like it sometimes not not
because of the fans but you know it's
like you're a person yeah that's like
you know certain days there was just you
know be an off phone call from my mom
about her having cancer or something and
then and then I got to go do a show and
and shake hands with kids and do all
this stuff and it's like I'm young I'm
not I'm like you know what I mean I'm 18
19 I don't fully know how to handle my
emotions yet and I needed to you know at
an older age I actually needed to kind
of be nicer to myself and tell myself
like yo as much as certain people told
you you were [ __ ] up or you were a
lost cause at those times or you know
you were acting reckless or you were a
little off like oh you had some stuff
going on with you man yeah you had the
world given to you so fast I was on
planes like 15 to 20 I was just non-stop
on planes like yeah like looking at prom
from my computer on Facebook it was
Facebook at the time that's crazy
looking at prom looking at all these
things and it was just like
ah damn like I just want to get lit so
young you know and do you feel like you
weren't really allowed to be a kid do
you think that that was kind of hard for
you just because like I see somebody at
the age of 15 who's like popping off but
you kind of become like the voice of of
the youth a lot right mm-hm and even
though you don't really recognize it
there's a lot of responsibility with
that that's kind of put on yeah not even
being a depression there's you're not
even asked if you can handle it they
just go but you know I look up to you I
want to be just like you be like yo I'm
15 who's my idols yeah man I you know
what it is I don't want to play victim
to the situation because that would be
that would be shitty I'm not gonna play
victim I know that I played a 50-percent
part of that yeah you know what I mean I
wanted to be a child star I want it to
be lit quick yeah you know so that's
also my I take accountability for that
but at the same time it was like some of
it could have been done a little better
you know and that's the other 50 on the
other side of you know life the label
everything well who was in your corner
to kind of help you just kind of funnel
all the good good [ __ ] and then kind of
get rid of all the [ __ ] because I
feel like I was a young person that's
the hard part like who's the person in
your clouds do that I can't say nobody
because a lot of people were in my
corner but I don't think a lot of people
really really understood me
mmm except for my mom yeah you know I'd
I mean I have it tatted on my face you
know like lovely lonely it was like I
was I really genuinely when my mom
passed away felt like I was like the
loneliest kid on earth because nobody
understood certain things I would say
there are certain ways I would act when
I was that age mmm and again I don't
want to play victim like you know I
acted out when I was really young I'm
never I'm gonna take full accountability
for that yeah but that's indicative of
somebody who's young though so I think
like you should yeah I shouldn't really
have I'm not saying I mean it's great
that you know you can look back at the
age of 15 and 16 and hold yourself
accountable for these things but for me
as in it like I look back now and I
gotta say sometimes young people are
just young and it's just it just takes
time for somebody to mature you know and
that's the hard part because yeah that's
why we have a lot of old heads they look
down at young people you're [ __ ] dumb
but if I I know those people I'm like
dog when you were younger you were way
worse
you know so there was there was
something that happened in your life
that allowed you to mature and whether
it was time where there was a human
being who knows what that was but those
things take steps in time to happen
right so yeah that mean there's a count
of billion that you should take for it
but there's also time where you were a
kid yeah and most 15 and 16 year olds
they don't go through what you went
through you know and that's that's the
hard part too that's why it's like I
want I always wonder lend somebody like
in your case like if you know who was in
your corner like that without that could
really be like yo stop or listen you
know or some [ __ ] you know I feel a lot
of people you know the label was yeah at
times though because I also do feel like
respectively I don't want to air their
business out that's just not how I am
but I will say I had went through a lot
of like hypocritical confusion mmm
and again they were younger at this
point in time too and a lot of the
people that were in my corner were
younger it was a different time but it
was just certain things like you know
you got to work hard bro everybody you
got to steer your ship you got to be the
leader you got to be the leader of this
[ __ ] I'm 19 mind you I'm 90 what the
[ __ ] do you mean this is like what the
[ __ ] like my friend just got his first
car like what the [ __ ] do you mean like
yeah weird to tell the kid that I look
at now like I have a I have somebody
around me at this moment hmm he's part
of my team
shoutout to Jack Parros um his name's
Jack and he's like suit he's a super
young kid but I never take him like like
I never try to Sun him like that because
of the amount of times I felt like I was
son it just really really weirded me out
at those times to kind of be pressured
into things and talked to like I was a
college football player when I really
was just like you know what I mean like
so cute like music yeah like that's it
you know but you know it's just I love
you jack sometimes and sometimes I'll
feel a bit all like speak a bit harsh to
them and then I'll even indicate it
within my own speech because of those
times it's like don't pressure him that
much man yeah dude like what are you
doing man like this is this is fun at
the end of the day with all of you yeah
be a nicer guy to this kid man
like it you know with that being said
it's like I just
with those moments in in my life I just
wish there was somebody in my corner at
least to be like is it yeah you know
again for example that you know you
steer the ship all this stuff but then
being told again with what I said about
like hypocritical things it's like on
the other side I get amen we need you to
hang out with some kids man being around
a lot of older people you know X&Y is he
got friends from NYU cuz I stay over
staying in New York at the time like I
want to go hang out with them you know
and it's like I just felt like like a
studied lab rat at certain points you
know and again it's not what how I
always say this it's not about what
people say it's how you make them feel
mmm and that's how I felt I felt like a
lab rat at certain point because they
will give you advice that didn't even
know what was it was sound either they
were just talking it sound like they
were just talking they're just like uh
maybe he should do this but they were
singing with a lot of copper yeah even
though they didn't really know and again
they didn't so that's not like they're
horrible people it's not like that it
was it was a lot of stuff I mean I got
talked to a certain way a lot and and I
know that because I go to therapy now
and I'm telling my therapist all this
stuff and she's just like looking at me
like you know what I mean like it's like
I know it's certain things weren't all
the way my fault you know but I took
accountability anyway as a kid and then
beat myself up for it a lot and I given
with a lot of I grew with a lot of
self-hate I grew a lot of shame and then
when things went a little sour I grew
with even more shame mmm
and it was you know the people in my
corner they did help me out and they
they were quite confident but I feel
like the love language just was a bit
harsh I feel like you know one of the
last sorry one of the last meetings I
had with them was just this meeting of
you know things aren't going well I
think you're gonna need to take a trip
back to Toronto and be a kid again and
kind of make some decisions and you know
and and finally but it was like it was
like almost the cage had been set free
the canary can go mm-hmm and I'm like
its I am 21 what yeah what yeah like
what are you talking about like yeah
like my young life is just beginning but
what yeah and then it was just weird and
or 2021 I don't even need to date these
things at this point but that's what
happened
and again like hearing I funny enough I
found out later on in my life that
during that whole period of time I was
anxious that anxiety rough anxiety like
yeah very weird anxiety like I would
literally like ask anybody around that
like I I'd like I mean it weirdly enough
I'm not doing it right now but I would
just be jittery in rooms and and at a
certain point in time it's like even you
know for example the people in my corner
I would shake and they'd be like help
stop [ __ ] shakin man yo see Nene one
successful person that shakes mm-hmm
it's just like that it's like you could
kindly tell me to stop shaking but on
this child star you want some you know I
mean and it's like it's not [ __ ]
shaking or like somebody would record me
doing it and then send it to the group
chat and I'd have to see you know what I
mean like just dumb [ __ ] and again I
don't want to be disrespectful II airing
anybody out but just to show you
perspective on how I felt back then it
was very weird you know very like very
just a lot of that stuff didn't need to
be said to me but at the same time I
don't feel like the world owes me [ __ ]
and I don't feel like it's like the
world is the world's going to be mean
sometimes so that's that's another thing
I kind of had to learn out all that and
I kind of have to learn to build my
thick skin and and really understand
these situations for what they are and
it's weird because you're kind of thrown
into a very harsh very harsh industry
though especially as a young star right
and I think like with with companies
like that they kind of look at people
like products right yeah so when they
see you do things that are actually very
[ __ ] human you know they yeah and in
a way though again like I'd have to come
from a place of understanding - it's
like they were family to me at a certain
point so I can never ever sit here and
say and and and victimize myself I can't
victimize myself I always tell myself
that like don't do that like you
through things they went through things
and it's it's it's that's what it is and
it's all the past so no lay it down but
also just be aware of what happened and
and reflect upon these feelings
sometimes because at a certain point in
time I'm going to have either an artist
under me saw an entity under me somebody
like Jack that I wasn't talking about
earlier you know that somebody that I'm
going to have to play that role with
sometimes not a Big Brother per se but
probably just a mentor I guess in
certain ways I think we're you to though
like like I understand the whole concept
of not wanting to like victimize
yourself and taking personal
responsibility but there's a point where
it kind of goes a little too much right
where you kind of hold this thing where
it becomes too much your fault you know
so there's like a really tricky balance
of that yeah because you know if we
because we could talk about personal
responsibility and we could tell
ourselves all the time it's like I
understand that's how the world is but
sometimes people are just [ __ ] up yeah
yeah and so I think it's so because I'm
more the opposite side right no eyes go
[ __ ] you guys I have mental clarity
after that and you know probably my side
I'm probably a little bit more opposite
of you where there's I do take a lot of
personal responsibility for the things
that I do but when people [ __ ] up around
me I do have a tendency to hold it
against them a lot yeah it's like it's
not that sense I don't have empathy
empathy for them right so for example
like you know I have friends who have
done [ __ ] up things but then I look
back at them I could be like oh well
they had a pretty [ __ ] up life growing
up betrayed them they've stabbed them in
the back and they're just putting that
energy on me but I still say that the
other day
[ __ ] you though I try to balance it out
a little bit like I understand you as a
person I'll [ __ ] with you anymore you
know with the people in my corner from
back then it's like we're cordial now of
course no things are civil now and I
love that I love that it's not for us
everybody said sorry to each other
everybody has paid their respects to
each other but at the end of the day as
well you know there's there are certain
things I don't forget mm-hmm and there
were certain moments you know in those
times that embedded into my personality
in a bad way and I'd like to be aware of
that and I'd like to of course gradually
change that over because you absorbed a
lot of that as a young person yeah I
feel like sometimes it leaks out yeah
definitely
this podcast is brought to you by purple
my friends I have
never slept any better until I fell in
love and put my beautiful body on a
purple mattress yes the best sleep of my
life and ever since I slept on a purple
mattress I've been waking up smarter and
why do I say that because I got a good
night's sleep and we all know that when
you sleep well
cognitively you do better than next day
and I use my brain all the time for work
so yes I do need good sleep and on top
of that can we talk about how cool it
keeps me I'm a sweaty man especially
during the summer and even if it's not
during the summer I still sweat a lot
well the technology behind a purple
mattress not only crêpes on your comfort
it also keeps you super super cool so
purple mattress thank you very much for
that a hundred night risk free child if
you're not fully satisfied you can
return your mattress for a full refund
backed by a ten year warranty and also
free shipping and returns you're going
to love purple and right now my
listeners will get a free purple pillow
with the purchase of a mattress that's
in addition to the great free gifts
they're offering site-wide just text
brain to eight four - eight eight eight
the only way to get this free pillow is
the text brain - eight four - eight
eight eight that's B R a I n - eight
four eight eight eight especially in the
way I talk my demeanor certain things I
that I do I always go home and I reflect
but not overthink I just reflect so you
know I even tonight like from certain
things that I said maybe I'll just
reflect upon them and you know and and
just hope that I didn't hurt anybody and
with what I said because I never want to
do that now I never want to actually
come out my neck about anybody that that
serviced me whether bad or good because
what with whatever you did I am me now
because of it so I can't you know what I
mean I can't be bitter like that I grew
up with a lot of a lot of hate on my
shoulder you know walking into and
walking into certain things you know I
didn't grow up with a father you know I
grew up with a stepdad and I and I loved
him you know what I mean like I could
grow with certain feelings but at the
same time like I'm growing to appreciate
you know what I mean yeah but I have
been through certain things in my life
that just the put hate in my heart well
did your dad deadly three or four I
think no super young so you know did you
not really have a relationship with him
work nah I don't even really know what
he looks like
oh really yeah like I don't really know
him like that um one of the last times I
heard of and I'm just gonna say this cuz
I can't say it and whatever it's my life
yeah people could take it out they want
but one of the last things I heard from
him or about him was he wanted
forgiveness from me or something mm-hmm
and I just couldn't really I don't
really have like a like it like you
don't know what to say it's just like
cool you know yeah like I get it but
like who are you to me anyway because I
love my stepdad yes more than anything
in the world so it's like yeah if it was
my stepdad sorry if it was my stepdad
and I that ever had a problem and he he
was on some [ __ ] like that you know
after some time by all means cuz you
have a foundation hell yeah like my
stepdad is the [ __ ] he's the greatest
person in the world to me
like I love him and I idolized him so
it's hard so when he asked for
forgiveness like I don't even know ya
know what am I supposed to say it's not
me being bitter like a lot of people
take it as like a bitter thing I just
take it as like I don't know you know
like even if you said the word like you
don't even know if you mean it or not
just like I guess I forgive you but
forgive what like I don't know who you
are yeah but you know I again like
certainty I don't have hate in my heart
for him like he made me yeah it is what
it is you know but at the same time like
I just don't know you so it is what it
is but I you know is that that right
that one of those situations in my life
like that's the situation in my life I
could look back and be like okay that
you know that was one of the chips on my
shoulder walking into life mmm you know
I had a lot of them but I think now I
feel I'm going through somewhat of a
resurgence so a lot of dudes negative
stuff is kind of flushing its way on out
in a great way that's a good I mean I'm
glad you're going to therapy a lot just
because I think someone especially all
the stuff that you went through it's
kind of good to have that person in your
corner that could help you talk you
through things outright and really
listen yeah and you know to take it away
from me too I feel like a lot of artists
you know if they have expendable money
should try it out oh yeah I suspect you
know this industry is really really
training like mentally draining so it
takes your spirit up yeah caught up in
so many expectations like you have to do
this if one song was good you got to
follow it up with another one and all
this stuff you know and I could sit here
and complain about it all day but it's
like they tell you from when you're
young you know you can't hate the player
hate the game yeah you know so it's like
I don't hate anybody who gets up there
but at the same time I you know I could
I could hate the game all day but I'm
playing it so it's like yeah yeah like
whatever like like entertainments very
difficult right and so even for me when
I when I was younger I wanted to be like
the biggest stand-up comic on earth
right and then this was the only thing
that was running through my mind aside
from like trying to do music when I was
younger then I wanted to be a comic and
so I let go of that I was like I better
come with them a musician so I moved to
comedy Yeah right musician by the way is
crazy
it's hard it's hard boys is crazy no see
that's what I was to you but that's the
thing about music though it's like it's
like I appreciate it music music a lot
right but I don't I don't love it yeah I
mean like when I see you make music I
can tell you love it right and that's
that's the biggest difference so when
even like you know I have a lot of great
fans you know you should do music it's
like I can't because I don't love it I
can't I can't dive into it I don't know
what my voices I don't know what my
sound is I don't know how to write
things because my heart's not there but
if you if you have comment like today
like I thought of something funny I
wrote a [ __ ] three pages of a new set
like that I can't do that with music I
can enjoy music I could appreciate it
like sonically I can understand there
but then if you ask me like you know get
in the booth and do something like yeah
I got nothing for you man yeah cuz the
heart's not there yeah you know what I
mean and that's like the biggest I guess
like that's what I want to tell young
people like when you want to do music
and they really want to make it their
life it's like your heart is yeah it's
like do you really because music is not
as easy as you think it is like it is oh
yeah and again rightfully so it's like
it has been a little easier like two
boys I mean I'm in the game myself and I
see that and for somebody who's been in
it for over a decade at this point you
know I I see people come and go and I
see a lot of people that you know get
into it for the wrong reasons
mhm
and then they made big I don't say they
make it but they make it to a point and
then it gets really real for them and
they're like do I really love this yeah
and it's like dude is what do you want
to do now you have this major label you
you know you set you sign for this deal
and you got this one big song but like
now you're you know questioning all this
it's because they found out they weren't
a musician they're like oh yeah I was
just having fun it's like yeah I wanted
to have fun with it keep it like that
like me and joy for what it is but when
you start stepping into a real stage
well now this [ __ ] becomes a business so
yeah when you know when you get signed
to a label you have contracts and stuff
and he's not just your music anymore now
it's your music and also there's there's
his tab lets me get money on their side
yeah and that's that hard part for
people to really balance you know yeah I
mean I was I was one of those for ya you
know what does he know no but I think I
mean I know this from just being myself
that there was a mission the whole time
and that was I mean the first one was
just like I knew I was always gonna be
famous and star for something like when
I'd like when I was a little kid I knew
that but you and Tim had that in common
you didn't have that is so funny cuz Tim
says the same thing he goes I always
knew that I was gonna be famous and that
was gonna be a star at something right
which is so interesting because not a
lot of people can self prophesize that
you know for real they had that mission
they had that goal and it happens yeah
that's how I know that my heart was in
it you know so I know a lot of kids and
a lot of younger kids will tell me you
know a lot of younger artists you know
people that they've influenced me and
it's just like you know some of their
goals like their main goals of her
followers are like you know a Rolex or
something yeah it's man like what do you
what do you really want though yeah you
know like tell me what you really want
cuz you're gonna get the Rolex and then
what's gonna happen you know what I mean
like you're gonna you're gonna get this
and then do you feel that it happened to
you like once once you kind of popped
off did you ever think about the what
next part
no weirdly it's hard right cuz I don't
know I never think about the what next
part because even like we I've talked
about that before where I made this like
film that got in the Sundance right and
I expected my life to be dedicated to
that for about like six or seven years
any film in sundance happened in my
first year and i didn't prep for the one
after
so I set this huge goal for my six seven
years of my life and then it happened
and then I sat after and I was like I'm
done okay what do I do next
you know think you know in a way in a
way I just there's a side of me that
knows I have like a certainty in in
certain things like I know for a fact
and I've had this attitude for about
ever since I went broke after the deal
mm-hmm I told myself it's gonna work
it's gonna happen and you were born for
it see what happens you know what I mean
I always had this see what happens
saying but the but the thing that
underlied all that the most was the
moment they let me in I'm [ __ ]
swinging I'm goin [ __ ] hard yeah
nobody's stopping me not not a single
soul is gonna tell me that it's not my
time yeah so just sit back have
everybody [ __ ] on you be overlooked for
a bit but for real like I [ __ ] do this
so the moment they let me in I'm fine
and that's why I like sometimes when I
feel like I'm under planned I'm still
good to myself I guess that's just a
confidence of me but I think you've
already had that side of having a label
behind you so you you you actually have
something an experience that a lot of
people don't have which is a you get to
play both right yeah there's the
unsigned artist and there's a signed
artist well the cool thing about
nowadays is like do you really need to
be a signed artist you know yeah
depending on what you really want out of
out of music or whatever you're doing
right so you you have an ability to pick
and choose now right yeah and so you've
got it before yeah do it again it's it's
probably the best time now more than
ever to try to be independent but at the
same time I don't want it totally [ __ ]
on a major label situation of course
because some people need that some
people actually you know I would
probably need that if we're being honest
cuz I know I know my [ __ ] so it's like
I'm able to finesse a deal like that a
lot of artists aren't they really aren't
I mean
you know a lot of kids I'm misguided so
they get into certain deals where it's
like they just want to get the [ __ ] out
of their area you know what I mean yeah
so it's just like [ __ ] I'm a [ __ ]
like you know you take all my merch you
know for me it's like I get deals me all
the time of like you know everything
looks good everything looks good but
then you see like one little fine print
oh and that fine print is like the
[ __ ] of everything it's like oh yeah
and we want your whole back catalogue
from prior to this oh and we want 70/30
our merch now are you [ __ ] kidding me
I'll put my [ __ ] blood sweat and
tears into my get back catalog yeah
that's me and Kyle shout out the K beats
that's me and K beats like in a [ __ ]
room making beats for [ __ ] weeks yeah
and spending our money and our time to
make these songs and you want to take my
back catalog just like that for what
because because you're giving me the uh
like I get it but I'm gonna make money
for you in the future like let me keep
this like let me keep this little piece
that's the hard part right because
that's what I'm saying that's there's a
stark difference between what you do and
what other artists do is because you are
a musician yeah most people can't do
that right they they can get a track
from somebody else they have they really
don't know where their input is they
don't know where to put the drums they
don't understand all these type of
things they don't understand why things
sound sonically good or bad money funny
you say that I feel like a lot of
artists now or like they've gotten to
this like egotistical point now where
they don't want to be fans of [ __ ]
there's this like I don't wanna be a fan
booing you only be fan Bowie likes crazy
[ __ ] music man what the [ __ ] is your
problem yeah you know and it's weird
because there's this like cool guy [ __ ]
in the industry and everybody says like
Elliot's fake la is fake like not really
like I used to be one of those people
I'm joking I used to be one of those
people and Tim's right whenever Tim
talks about it like I actually like I
might preach dude it's like it's like
you just a lot of people just got to
cool yeah they don't want to listen to
other people they don't want to like I
buy merch from artists I like oh for
sure and I pay it forward like that cuz
I know that other people buy my stuff
cuz they like me what you don't want to
be a fanboy like what the [ __ ] people
are a fanboy overused
yeah appreciate music like how everybody
else does and you're never going to lose
the love cuz that's it's yeah I just I
love I mean for lack of a better
expression I love this [ __ ] I love the
game yeah I love like I just love when I
can be a kid again
and listen to certain albums and like
not have to care about the technical
aspects of certain things or you know me
being in the industry for a long time I
was the snobby kid that would like if
some if a girl showed me a song I'd be
like oh the mixing on this record is
terrible and like I don't like the
material it shut the [ __ ] up yeah shut
up listen to the song enjoy it this girl
likes it cuz the beat is nice this girl
likes it cuz you know as minimal as the
lyrics are she understands them yeah you
know what I mean not everything has to
be tippity toppity doin [ __ ] yeah
lyrical miracle spiritual and [ __ ] and a
lot of people are like that in a regard
or like you know they just there are so
many expectations even from fans
sometimes or like the consumer that I
feel like even the people that create
and consume are so much more I always
tell people this like take a break
sometimes off making [ __ ] and just let
the [ __ ] be made in front of you
sometimes and I again like I feel a lot
of people are in this like and
especially the internet is in this like
24 hour motivation you have to always be
on your [ __ ] each shift 30 years it's
cool I understand it but like yo
sometimes I go I laid on the couch and I
watched animation yeah podcast you know
why you need that cuz I needed it sore I
did ten push-ups yesterday that [ __ ]
hurt that's some real advice - yeah I
had the same problem when I when I see
people who are you know new
up-and-coming filmmakers right mm-hmm
they there's a couple of things that
happen when I watch a film
you know there's rotten tomatoes and all
other stuff right right when I watch a
film people come out and they had their
review for it right it's like hold on a
second man were you even watching it
yeah like why don't you just watch it
for what it is and then maybe the second
time around you can critique it on like
the technical
pics because that's that's the hard part
when sometimes when I people don't
understand one of my favorite [ __ ]
films is nacho libre right not to Libre
is one of my so favorite comedy films of
all the time and there's so many people
that think I think it's dumb because I
didn't go in there trying to dissect you
say that wasn't even a real Mexican
accent I don't give a [ __ ] funny I
watched it for what it is yeah yeah and
that's the hard part too even with music
one of the hardest things I have to
listen to all the time is when an album
drops and they go best album ever it's
only been out for an out yeah how did
you listen to the whole thing yeah how
or when somebody just automatically
think something is trash yeah like you
didn't wait yeah you gotta sit in it for
a second yeah back in the day back in
the day when you so if I wanted to check
out an album it was either in like a
magazine or it was somebody talking
about on the radio but there were people
who are reviewing music and they were
given the album ahead of time like a
couple of weeks maybe a month ahead of
time right and they were allowed to
listen to it for a month sit with it and
then put their review out but now it's
more about it's not about whether an
information is right or if it's a real
opinion it's about who can get it out
there yes and it [ __ ] up a lot of
things specifically with music like I
see it a lot big oh that [ __ ] was the
best album of all time you've only heard
it ten minutes ago
impossible you can't say that and then I
read [ __ ] a thousand [ __ ] articles
about this album when it just dropped
it's like yo impossible yeah cheer with
it for like you don't understand that
when an artist sometimes especially if
you really are [ __ ] with them and you
appreciate them you know they're a
musician
they took months maybe a year to make
this [ __ ] album and then you judged
it in 10 seconds like yo listen to it
and then you could say it's trash then
you could say it's good but at least
like give it a [ __ ] chance you know
yeah a lot of people don't do that I
mean it's even like in the Drake thing
like so many people are just so like
when when Drake first came out it was
like nobody really gave certain things a
chance just like it was so weird also as
a kid that lived from like it was from
that City to hear people just be so like
dismissive sometimes over him well now
look at how he turned out well that's
because he had to be he was he was a
pioneer though like yeah he had to be
the pie look you know Kanye started off
with that whole thing
about I don't have to be a thug to rap
you know and he really allowed people be
like yo this guy's wearing [ __ ] you
know polo collared tees right [ __ ]
colors and you can't say [ __ ] to him cuz
his musics dope for real and then you
know Drake had to do the same song I
think what other people were doing to
but he really did it yeah yeah well did
it really well and you know during that
time too it was still on that cusp of
like you had to be a thug to rap UNITA
means so a lot of people were hating on
him because he was he had popular music
but they just didn't want to label him
as a hip-hop artist yeah they said no
he's an armed be seen I remember that
argument a lot it does not he's a singer
I was like no he's a rapper
he's patterning you know well the
perception of him was teeter-tottering
yeah yeah
I'm happy you know for what he's turned
out to be because it's proved to a lot
of people that you know don't have
certain expectations and I was ever hit
or two cuz when I came out I loved his
music I just didn't like him you have it
yeah I met you but then when somebody
would ask me is like well why don't you
like them is just like I know some about
his [ __ ] face I just hate it but I
always listen to ya could hate on a game
yeah that's what I was about to say I've
always heard things like that but
everybody has always just listened to
his music either way can't you can't
deny his talent it's impossible cream
always rises to the top that's what it
is definitely and I feel like you know
with with all that being said it's like
he's one of those main people it's like
when you're the biggest thing in the
world people are just gonna hate on
things to hate on it's easy people
literally hate on things like the moment
like that he drops like the moment they
come out and it's like trash emojis for
like three days and then you hear it in
the club and it's ringing off of course
you know and again people just want to
be quick to the joke
they want to be quick to the trash dough
this is trash I want to post this meme
to say this is trash yo one mad when
swimming came out by Mac I swear I've
seen countless memes like Mac Miller
drop me you know what I mean it like
that
yo he passed away and like every boy
every body was on his dick after and
it's like yo [ __ ] you yeah I know the
real truth like by oh yeah it was just
stupid but it's like people just want it
to be funny and people are always gonna
want to be funny so it's like at the end
of the day like I'm not I see it as like
you know
people have fast reviews for things
again I don't I don't need to like call
people out I don't need to be that guy
anymore I just look at you I know my
cool man you just yeah be like you man
you're not gonna oh you're never going
to enjoy music if you're just gonna be
over critical all the time about smart
though I think that's like great advice
for a lot of people like you got to be a
fan first before you do anything else
cuz we're always your inspiration coming
from yeah I always hear creatives just
like be like you know Moon Moon and
spine I'm not funny yes because bro
you're living an engulfed life in your
ego yeah like is like these are artists
that are bigger than me to tell me this
[ __ ] this podcast is brought to you by
skill share my friends it's time to
explore new skills deep in existing
passions and get lost in creativity with
skill shares online classes do you like
learning outside of traditional ways of
Education for me I love skill show
because I have knowledge at my
fingertips because there is a huge
library of knowledge for me to access on
my own accord on my own time when I am
ready to learn because I love pursuing
education outside of traditional
education I'd like learning the way that
I want to now for those of you who don't
know what skill share is let me just
break it down for you skill share is an
online learning community that offers
membership with meaning with a lot to
explore real projects to create and the
support of fellow creatives Skillshare
empowers you to accomplish real growth
and guess what it's also incredibly
affordable especially when compared to
pricy in-person classes and workshops an
annual subscription is less than ten
dollars a month now for me I love
photography so I've been taking the
fundamentals of DSLR photography class
and it's been helping me just kind of
learn a lot of the basics that I didn't
know just trying to learn things on my
own just doing like youing using um just
like online stuff that was very vague
with things but when I take like the
skills sugar classes it helps me really
just hone in on a lot of basics that
allows me to explain explain expand into
more complicated things so hop on that I
love skill sure I use it constantly so
the skills share is a proud sponsor of
genius brain explore your creativity at
skill share
calm / brain and get to three months of
premium membership that's two whole
months of unlimited access to thousands
of classes for free get started and
joined today by heading to Skillshare
comm / brain that Skillshare dot-com /
brain who do your favorite artists right
now Drake of course Drake Gambino
childish gambino I feel like I related
to him a lot trying to thank the baby I
feel I relate to him he's like a father
he's like one of my favorite new artists
that came out yeah incredible what to me
is a new artist anyway for edible like
just from the visuals to everything and
he's very hands-on from what I hear I
just like him as an artist to be the
confidence he exudes just like Danny you
look like you've been doing this since
you were a [ __ ] child dude yeah yeah
and it's it's a showman's confidence he
has just very he's just like he's one of
those figures in a room he'll walk in a
room you'll really he'll really see you
know and that's a true you know he's one
of you get one every like two three
years yeah you know a superstar mmm and
it's always good I feel like the world
needs a superstar every now and then and
especially on top of that like a hip-hop
superstar yeah I mean you always need -
I mean you know what's kind of crazy
flavor but we were talking about how
there's a certain amount of young people
who just wanted to be lit and they kind
of they they kind of rode that wave out
and it's funny how like I said is - a
while back I was like I appreciate you
know people like lil yachty came out
yeah I didn't understand it it wasn't my
thing but if my thing about hip-hop is
like I think like the youth kind of
speaks towards his evolution right so
it's like when all the purchase says
that's not hip-hop well before they had
that there was somebody before you that
was saying that what you were doing
wasn't hip-hop yeah it evolves
differently but the interesting thing
about their way was I feel like their
wavers started dying out and now they
want more now people just want a little
more lyrics again and it's like it was
kind of weird how that shift happened
where they were just like nah I just
want the Casio keyboard I want some
random drums and I want some fun music
and
still there and still poppin but now
it's starting to a little go back a
little bit where people are looking for
a little more substance again yeah I you
know I had its period of time I have to
sit that out too I knew that too as an
artist myself and a rapper myself i
kinda have to sit my rap stuff out for a
bit yeah because she was a little too
wordy mm-hmm I put out an album called
rustle and it was like like I have a
tracklist like tatted on my leg like it
was very important to me yeah still is
till this day I feel like it's one of my
greatest works of art that I feel like
people should definitely appreciate but
again that's that's me saying that so
now you [ __ ] appreciated [ __ ] yes I
would never want to force people though
but I feel like that but I put it out it
was a very cinematic album a lot of it
was almost like a tell-all in a sense
and I think I released it just at the
wrong time that's it I feel like it was
a great album just at the wrong time you
know it wasn't an arrow of a lot of
minimal music making in which again like
whoops in which again like I can't hate
the game it was frustrating it was very
odd to kind of go through that but I
couldn't hate the game you know these
guys have to pop off if that that it
that is all who knows right because it's
funny cuz even though you say that like
those those songs are still getting
spins as we speak yeah I know oh I know
for a fact like fact when when when and
I say when this [ __ ] really cause like
my goal is like superstar like I'm gonna
be the biggest thing in the world yeah
when I get to that point all that old
material is gonna be rediscovered and
enjoyed you know even my d-pryde stuff
like I have clean music like I could
play that for my kids let's know my own
stuff like what artists can do that that
can pull up their old old music and be
like oh I didn't cuss on any of this
yeah I'll play it for my kid my kid can
see the legacy from there anything the
thing is especially about your music I
think like when you rapped or when you
created music it was very representative
and it still is representative of what
you go through at the time like you
never spoke about stuff that you didn't
go through yeah I felt like it a certain
sorry I felt like at a certain era I did
when you were super young yeah yeah but
it seems like your music now is like
it's only extremely very honest yeah do
you think that has to do a lot with like
your mom passing because I know there
was a point to when I was following you
like you just disappeared and you were
and and you know I didn't know what you
were going because I didn't know you
want a personal level I was just a fan
anyway right um yeah my mom passed away
and I felt like when was that by the way
was a 2015 okay it was like as a
creative I've never been more motivated
than ever but I knew that I knew that
there was a lot of work to be done on me
yeah so in terms of just like
disappearing again it was it was for the
better in a certain sense like I kind of
needed to step away from being the I
didn't like that like certain aspects of
about myself for like excused
you know he's Asian so he gets a little
bit of a pass cuz we don't expect like
you know what I mean or like he's young
wow he's so much younger than everybody
and he's like I hated things like that
I just wanted to be considered as good
because I was good that's the way and
exactly and I felt like sometimes you
just need to step away at that point cuz
people will just take you for granted
so um when I did that I reflected upon a
lot of my music that you know was very
like I don't drink I don't smoke I don't
do this I don't do that you know it's
like I was just saying so many things at
the time that were like very like this
is me yeah you know and it kind of it
kind of made it weird in the long run
when I wanted to drink or when I wanted
to do certain things cuz I felt engulfed
in like my musical beliefs like oh man I
said this on a slow I mean listen it
rejected me from a lot of life of course
but you know that goes once again you
got to realize that goes back to you
being a young person that's young people
very young and impressionable yeah cuz
we when I was younger I hated beer and
then what my mom says to I started
liking beer a lot and my mom was like
did you hate beer I was like yeah I did
it she goes you know why it's cuz life
gets better so [ __ ] is better yeah you
know we can't get so like I used to be
that kid on my records oh that would be
like I'm never gonna do this yeah buddy
blah blah blah and it's weird because
I'll have fans I hold me to that
everybody says we're never gonna do this
and all that but I said
and I never really cared I said I wasn't
gonna have [ __ ] before I got married
when I was younger I was a hardcore
Christian kid and I got and I swam in
that [ __ ] so I'm yeah there's a lot of
things that we say when were younger and
it's because this this I don't like a
strand of people not understanding that
people can change in their thoughts
change all the [ __ ] time like people
can go back to every single one of my
old videos ago Dave didn't you say this
I did say that I believe it at the time
I don't believe it now [ __ ] yeah
I said Cosby wasn't a rapist yeah how
many times but he raped I've said I'm
like the biggest hypocrite on earth you
know why it's because I'm a very
passionate purchase so sometimes when I
say things it's rooted in truth at the
moment but if if somebody allows me to
listen to the truth or maybe we can
persuade me then of course I'll tonight
I'll be like yeah yeah like that dude
that'll just like know right when he's
not dying on any [ __ ] Hill dude like
this is not my thing like that's a good
trait that my career has changed
multiple times like a writ like I said
originally I only wanted to be a
stand-up comic and I found out while
doing YouTube that I don't really like
doing stand-up comedy it's just a hobby
of mine I just really like helping
people that's the biggest thing that was
then it was a long road to get to that
point it's like well why did you do
comedy in the first place and had to
think but think about it well why did I
do comedy I just wanted to make people
laugh so yeah so do I really want to do
stand-up because I could help people and
make people feel good through any other
Avenue besides cambia eec where you fit
in exactly so then I started trying you
know then I started doing YouTube you
know then YouTube was making people
laugh but it wasn't stand-up yeah right
so there's a lot of different things
that you find out when you get older you
just can't marry people to the stuff
that they say when they're younger yes
because people change yeah I used to and
again going back to what we were talking
about before it's like with my lyrical
content I used to want to make sure that
I was like a role model at all times
mm-hmm I look back at [ __ ] now and I'm
like I really don't care if I am or if
I'm like I have the conscious in my head
to always be you know what I'm
aggressive yeah but my Nisha's and
positivity like I can't [ __ ] do that
I'm very happy on the Internet and I
am happy in real life but I'm also like
reality like yeah you know I'm happy
when I need to be when I'm not I take a
break from it hmm
and yeah I feel like some of my music
back then you know bringing it back to
that is like I would write about certain
feelings when I wasn't feeling that way
so I can date back to certain songs that
other people would be like you know that
really helped me I blah blah blah and in
my head of my cat I'll help you but I
kind of just I wrote that yeah that
reason you know I didn't do it because
it was me hurting and going through that
yeah I just wrote it from because I'm a
good songwriter yeah yeah and I don't I
wanted to say that because like a lot of
artists are like that or they'll write a
certain song and like they don't all the
way feel it but it'll be like their
biggest song or something and then
they'll just run off that like yo okay I
really meant what I said on that song
sometimes it's like no you really didn't
like or like are you writing all your
stuff right originally yeah everything's
from me yeah do you have another writer
writing partners just you just me but I
do listen to people in the room you know
if it's yeah that's [ __ ] hard thank
you I can't do that to say my life like
hey yeah you know what's funny is sorry
to cut you off
no go ahead um a lot of my songwriting
and I tell that everybody this a lot of
my songwriting came from being shunned
like a lot of that skill from
songwriting came from being shunned I
was like around a lot of writers in my
time in the industry and dude as a kid
that does this like I [ __ ] do this to
be put in a room with like eight other
people that have publishing advances
they're all there because they got
signed it and then the this [ __ ]
publishing label they all got their new
Christian Dior's own you guys got the
whole just got my advance starter pack
and I'm in there and I'm supposed to be
in this writing session and it's [ __ ]
like eight other people just singing
like girl you know girl you know girl
you know what about you bro what do you
got girl you know girl and it's [ __ ]
like eight hours passes by and I'm
sitting there like yo you all are living
in too much luxury this song would have
been done in like 30 minutes if I
[ __ ] touched it yeah but I've just
been sitting here trying to absorb
because everybody in the [ __ ]
industry has been telling me don't get
it to other yourself like blah blah blah
nah like I can write better than
all these people in this [ __ ] room
and I'm just sitting here seeing how
[ __ ] privileged everybody is all you
work out of big studios I work out of if
I [ __ ] go through a problem with a
girl I'm running the [ __ ] home and I'm
writing about it yeah and I have my mic
there and I'm gonna jot all this the
[ __ ] down it's all gonna sound mad
honest but it's like and again I can't
hate on writing camps but writing camps
just have this like thing that burns the
fun and burns like the real passion out
well because I just like points all them
were just looking for points yeah
remember I said that word I want my
points it's like so wack because it's
not collaborative and that's why I like
producers more than songwriters
sometimes a bit because producers really
like shout out to all the producers who
they work so cooperatively like laying
certain drums down and then like
producers landing out loops and and
samples like like ill mind and that
community is so supportive sometimes
it's not like with songwriters an artist
like there's a little bit of an ego and
everybody just wants their time to shine
so then you get these sessions of people
just trying to butt in with their ideas
all the time and it's like too many
cooks in the kitchen and I couldn't
stand that as a kid because I'm like
this isn't collaborative this is just
this is just people just trying to
everybody is just trying to explain how
big their dick is right now yeah
nobody's really trying to [ __ ] this girl
mm-hmm you know metaphor yeah like yo
one of y'all gotta try all of you you're
just sitting here being cocky about it
now let me say I'm the type of guy that
is stepped forward and asked her for a
number because I really do this do you
get what I mean like I will step up and
I will write the whole first verse in
front of you and the hook and show you
that I'm enjoying myself because I have
it playing I'm cutting all my own vocals
to it I'm hearing it play back and I'm
being happy with the play back instead
of like second-guessing myself cuz eight
other people are in the room and and
there's motion and on our writer we have
all that likes too much again too much
luxury can kill you sometimes and a lot
of these dudes got too much luxury you
know and again bring it back to my point
I always always the quiet kid in those
rooms and I was always the
like I didn't have the louder voice so I
didn't really have too much of an input
and I didn't have like the credentials
nor the so it was like mm I I'm gonna do
it my way this is that I like I don't
see that stuff is intimidating a lot of
artists do and to any artist don't
[ __ ] do that because big studios are
just bigger places to record your stuff
yeah that's literally it that's one of
the biggest lessons I've learned from
this stuff that's why I love [ __ ] a
[ __ ] Lil Wayne he just had an
engineer go with him everywhere that he
went he recorded in his [ __ ] hotel
one of my favorite like inspirational
clips from him was like from his
Sundance documentary where he's like in
the hotel recording swagger like us in
mecca and yeah he just got like all this
stuff aside he has a bat like a duffel
bag with a mic and he sets it up miss no
one on the corner got swagger like uh
Chuck like and he's really really doing
it and like you see the screw-ups and
you see like all the takes and that to
me was like it really expresses like you
don't really need the big studio all the
time you don't really need eight writers
to be around you or all your boys are a
bunch of girls in there for the vibes
and sometimes you do need that but a lot
of people want to rely on that rely on
yourself rely on your brain rely on your
create your creativity if you really do
this it's gonna be anywhere possible
yeah you want to get moods but you don't
want to ever be dependent like a lot of
people are dependent on getting higher
getting drunk I smoke a lot I smoke
before I got here but I'm not dependent
on that too you know what I mean if you
didn't had you don't you could still do
whatever yeah dude and I know that I've
Riedel I still write songs sober you
know what I mean and it's like I know
y'all do that [ __ ] dude I can't smoke to
save my life the moment I smoke I'm done
like I can't my eyes glaze over yeah
that's a good feeling it's I mean when
you know it's a tolerance thing I feel
like it goes hand in hand with music I
don't want to be too dependent on it
with my music making but it is nice it's
so [ __ ] nice tastic Oh bro I never
knew how [ __ ] amazing it was until I
actually had specially cuz you have
anxiety like yeah that [ __ ] helps like I
yeah I use CBD all the time before I go
spar before I have someone throw their
fist in my [ __ ] face
I take C I take C B drops cuz helps me
relax
because then it's like these punches are
gonna come but I'm gonna see ya man and
I feel like you know it affected my life
in a great way
as I started smoking weed I've been a
little more laid-back and wanting to
figure out why I'd be mad at certain
times because it's like a present thing
you know even in therapy I learned to
sit there and you know if you're kind of
going through a little too much like
name four things in the room to yourself
and like get present yeah I feel it felt
like like I don't mean to bring weed in
my mental health but I actually felt
like we'd kind of gave me that presence
like I'm gonna smoke and I'm listening
to the song and I'm channeled into this
song and now I'm sitting in this room
holy [ __ ] that's a beat and okay I'm
right back in well you know what I mean
like some people [ __ ] weed is magic
for them yeah that's like my biggest
thing because I always tell people when
when you know cuz I just be a youth
minister right mhm and so you know after
I stopped being a youth minister some of
these kids obviously if I saw them
outside you know they're living a
different life maybe some of them are
Christian anymore but maybe they smoke
or some [ __ ] right and you know they'd
always ask you so how come you never
really you know smoked or anything else
like I thought I was like well it's not
because I didn't want to it's just
because he didn't it doesn't mix with me
some people it just works well with some
people doesn't he's just different you
know yeah oh you man yeah I used to be a
big hater rightfully so in a sense
because the environment that I was
around that wasn't it was nice too yeah
I was always attached to like my my
certain friends are to be video gaming
into like four and then it's like they
would have money problems and it's like
yeah because all you do you know are
certain friends that had just you know
I'd have certain friends in my life
that'd be like yo you know I was a young
boy so it was like they didn't ever
smoke weed but they associated with bad
stuff because of course like times right
I'm younger you remember like at times
her weed it was a little taboo it was
like it was seen as a drug and I had
people around me thinking it was a drug
and it's like yo man I'm gonna [ __ ]
beat your ass if you ever [ __ ] smoke
that [ __ ] and it's like ok ok yeah and
then me having to [ __ ] see that same
person go take a hit and be like yo bro
you wanna try that sound like you're a
[ __ ] idiot
yeah and I always associated it with
that and I and I hated on that until I
turned older then honestly like it was a
it was
really it was it was a cute girl that
got me into it tight you know and and I
was like yo what's the worst I got and
I'm with this girl I trust her you know
what I mean if I green out she's right
here yeah and I did it and I was like oh
I can handle my son
yeah great are you kidding me this is
how you guys feel
yeah you know what I mean like I'm in
like are you kidding I can't I can yeah
I used to smoke cigarettes so I smoked
cigarettes when I started living in New
York City and I get such a child
starving like this is being the stressed
out kid like thirteen year old Smokey's
oh my god yeah man when I was old enough
to finally buy them I just would do it
but I had to I had to get rid of that
and you had to go to the city where it's
the most expensive
exactly man you threats and all that but
you know at a certain point in time I
was like oh this this motion is like
this is the biggest this is the thing
it's the eviction it's a deal sealer so
maybe I'll just put a joint there and
build my tolerance up because at the
same time I also saw that I was in a bit
of an industry where like we'd brought
people together I saw it in that aspect
like oh maybe I should like also a lot
of like times like I would just see
certain people smoke or like you know
certain girls like they would just smoke
and they just not have a buddy to do it
with and it would be the perfect time to
go say something to them or like talk to
them and I never wanted to meet that
point where I felt peer pressured to do
that but that was in my head that was
like how I was as a person mm-hmm I'm
like I'm always down for [ __ ] not like
drugs but if I see that it doesn't harm
me and I'm good they're like imma go for
it because there's some sort of
certainty and like comfort there so it's
like say I don't drink like that I get
like I'm a heavyweight in a certain
sense but I also just don't drink like
that
yeah me too I'm not the guy that's gonna
order a scotch every time at dinner yeah
but if I'm a situational drinker either
like I don't drink at home yeah but if
we and one less I'm I don't like let's
say the lady want some wine or some [ __ ]
I'm good yeah but you're not gonna see
this stock of liquor here
my fridge but if I'm out and people are
drinking and like you wanna drink I'm
like yes yeah I know to like at certain
points it's like you know if there's uh
say like you know somebody's meeting
with me and it's like they're off a vibe
and they're very very energetic and they
went through a good day and it's like
I'll see it to that like you meant
you've had a good day you want to go
dinner with me and you're one of my
friends and you want to go say [ __ ] it
like I want I want to let's do it
you know Scotchies I want I need some
whiskey I'll jump right the [ __ ] in you
know I'd be like cool cuz I don't want
to be that guy to leave you in that good
mood and just I mean you know I I will
always participate and the same thing
was with weed you know what I mean like
I saw certain people that I was like oh
that's not a bad person and they are
really indulging themselves and I'm
around them you know I might as well
it's not gonna hurt me and you know I
built my tolerance to that point where
it couldn't so it got me into a lot of
good situations it's interesting because
I feel like we'd kind of gave you
control cuz like for me weed doesn't
give me control oh really like I
over-thinker that's like the biggest
reason why I can't sleep because my mind
races right it's really so when I even
when I smoke it's terrible because my
mind still racing but I can't sit in it
yeah I mean so because I can't sit and
being high it's just it's just me saying
I want to stop being high Wow
so like the complete my mind races all
the time yeah and it's like a good way
to kind of have it be like that's like
that's not what that's what I thought it
was going to do for me to do that you
smoking the wrong we just like I want to
stay some [ __ ] profound but it's not
coming out and starting to piss me off
yeah and like you're the only person
that smokes it gets mad I'm like I'm
here Taylor right yeah it's weird
because when I first got into it there
are a lot of like you know weed heads
that would you know give me certain
strains or like and then again you're
like this kid that just got into it so
you're like all these people are
delusional it's people like it is like
shut up you know it wasn't until a
friend show me like like to dream is
just raining out dude that should yeah
that's why blue dream is great gelato is
great like there are certain strains
that really just get me like less like
you know crazy and I'm just more so like
able to even like
almost like a conversation yeah like I'm
able to do it and I'm able to know what
I'm saying and you know what I mean when
I'm off like a sativa or something or
something that's a little more like up
on the cerebral effects it's like I'll
want a party yeah like I'll want to make
music all night like literally spend the
next seven hours in this hyper high so
it really does depend but of course you
never won't really want to get dependent
on anything and everything in moderation
you know so it's always good to have
like a clean break every now and then
but I do like I don't like things are
getting a little less conservative and
people are kind of accepting it
especially in like Canada in Toronto
like people are so much more like like
my dad asks for CBD oil and [ __ ] the
other day and my right is it's so funny
because my mom she has carpal tunnel and
then I was giving her see me I didn't
tell her what it was though and I was
like try this measure this is great I
was like that's a weed woman yeah your
[ __ ] face this stuff is greatest uses
all the time yeah because she needs it
like yeah wonder [ __ ] [ __ ] is
inflamed the only thing that works for
is the CBD ointment yeah and even for me
like I use CBD [ __ ] all the time
but I like I use CBD [ __ ] all the time
do I have to because I might just [ __ ]
that by getting so many like [ __ ] car
accidents and also there so I don't have
that [ __ ] [ __ ] shot Weed Man yeah I'm
happy that um I slid into a vise it's a
little catered to my everyday life
yeah and I don't know I was like I'm
stoned all the time now in a great way I
feel like after a life of so much being
on edge mm-hmm and a lot of pressure I
finally can like enjoy my 20s being high
[ __ ] and just making great stuff and
like whenever I meet up with other
creatives that do talk to me about like
you know what do you do aside from music
man like bubble I always tell them like
I just I smoke weed and I like I just
I'll go paint stuff or like yeah like so
pants and podcast for hours it's like a
good thing for me to just like well
that's the cool thing about what you do
and that's what I'm saying like when I
when it goes back to it like you could
like I just can't tell you love your art
because your fun is also your art you
and that's the hard part for a lot of
people right it's just that when you
don't have one thing that you can hone
on you kind of become a jack of all
shits yeah I mean like you're you're
kind of a kid is you're kind of okay
that you're kind of okay at that and
people see that as great talent but what
I see sometimes is an unfocused human
being it's like you actually haven't
figured out what you wanted yet right
you are just Dibble dabbling in stuff
and you kind of like it when people say
you're kind of good at that you're kind
it makes you feel good but see for
somebody who's a honed artist and that
kind of art can bleed into a lot of
things right like for example like
you're really great at music but because
you're really great at music music kind
of encapsulates a lot of things as art
like your music videos it also bleeds
into that a vision for your music videos
finding a great team DP for this [ __ ]
and then on top of that and then that
bleeds into your clothing it's like okay
then these kind of things all work
together yeah man again like I do this I
tell people I'd do this like I when I
was a kid it was like I was put to the
expectation of like yo you're the Asian
guy meaning Asian artist you know you
rep for the Asians and all and I get it
I really do but I rep with my face I'm a
pop-up and that's not my scapegoat or my
niche you know what I mean I always like
people know that and and I think the
love for the music really helped me
prevail out of that box because I was in
that box for sure I think maybe that's
how you started but I don't even think
that's there anymore yeah exactly
I love what I do I really pushed that I
pushed let me make music let me write
music let me let me literally just be me
you know because I really love this [ __ ]
and I want to stay in it and that's
something that's that's that's the huge
difference that's why when I hear your
music I'm like how the [ __ ] did you
write that hook thing because that if
you've never written music before
writing the hook is the [ __ ] hardest
part the hook and the second verse is
the hardest part to me first verse fine
cuz you're just mumbling whatever
whatnot this sounds dope then you got to
go to the hook and then you have to
think about the second [ __ ] verse
which is my killer it's like oh yeah
this I work my moods so that's how I
even write choruses in the first place
like I'll tell the mood of the song and
I'll be like okay like nice I feel this
way oh let me freestyle and I'll just
freestyle [ __ ] and then I'll just like
pop up and be
the way it is they and a lot of again a
lot of it comes from just like like
really honestly I just don't overthink
it to like I don't go in with like this
big mission anymore to make a hit I just
like I don't even record every day like
that anymore like oh there's like that
the misconception about like that I'm
like I am very hardworking but I'm not
again I'm not like 365 each [ __ ] like
you know what I mean like I'm nice to
myself if I don't feel like recording
I'm not and that's why I like that I
don't have to work in a studio I have a
record label advance in which they're
paying for a studio for me to work out
so I mandatorily have to be there like
no like yeah I'm I make my own hours I
do what I want and when it I feel like
it's gonna come out it's gonna come out
yeah and like to live in a luxury of
that is like the best for creation
because you start writing for you and
you don't you don't write for oh label
ask for another hit I hate that mmm they
know like the label will get a hit from
me because I am the guy for that and I
know that and I love what I made you
start to go into more singing I could do
it hey nobody would have known yeah I
could do it like I felt like I could do
it and I was like I'm gonna do it and
people might be mad but I don't care cuz
I could do it so at the end of the day
that and you've gotten better and better
yeah at it cuz I could tell you practice
it because like when I heard your music
at first it was like oh it's a little
shaky and then you got better and then
your vocally just started starting in
better yeah been practicing he's been
practicing a lot yeah you could you
could tell in the music that I just
started listening I started listening to
music more and being a fan more rather
than I was always about myself I was
always trying to redeem d-pryde so a lot
of those records were just me trying to
chase a hit you know granted a lot of
people are fans of certain records and I
can't sit here and not like them but I
just know you know there were certain
records where I was experimenting a
little too hard or like you know but at
the end of the day a lot
it was just me having to smoke weed
sometimes at the end of the night and
listen to records all night and I would
relate to certain records or I would be
like oh maybe I should try that with my
voice you know what I mean or smart yeah
that's great that's a sweating you go in
the backseat and being like maybe I'm
not as good as I think sometimes we're
not in a way to bring yourself down you
just can't create art if you're not
consuming art one of the hardest things
that I had to deal with especially when
I was finding people who want to do
videos for me I would ask them straight
off the bat right strap the jump they go
oh I want to be a videographer I want to
make videos cool cool cool I'm like
great give me three of your favorite
directors and tell me three of your
favorite films yeah yeah I don't know
then what the [ __ ] are you talking about
yeah haven't consumed enough you don't
you don't know what you want to create
because you haven't even seen what other
people have done there's so many great
people out there that are doing things
and are killing it doesn't mean that
you're stealing from them which a little
bit we are but it's just working
installing it yeah it's just like it's
our influences you know I mean like how
do you not how do you not how do you try
to create something when you have no
foundation for your art yes that's the
crazy part for me right every the
greatest artist if you ask them who
their favorite people are they go boom
boom boom yeah boom I grew up listening
to this I grew up doing this and they'll
give you time stamps and like certain
things that resonated with them you know
like again like there's this big like
hip-hop you tube kind of perception of
kids like they'll be like and even
they're like that with my music like
[ __ ] all this [ __ ] that's out I
listen to you and I'm like okay express
that you listen to me but you don't have
to say [ __ ] all the [ __ ] that's out
yeah enjoy it as much as minimal as it
could be or not satisfying to you
there's everybody that's on got on
because people like them mm-hmm so as
much as you get to sit there and hate on
everybody people like them so I got to
see why they're on their platform yeah
you know for the songwriters and people
I hate I'm like okay you're here for a
reason so I can't all the way hate you
but at the same time you got to just be
open to it you know like okay I'm not
the biggest fan of this but if it comes
on to the club maybe I'll listen to it a
bit you know or I'll try to see what
girls think I always try to see what
girls think about
music you know as a man I just always
feel like I hate being overly manly I
mean I hate being overly masculine I'm
quite in touch with my feminine side and
I really that's why again going back to
the singing thing like I people
understand I really got along with girls
growing up like I was a big like I love
being I was always around like five
girls like always like you know that
kind of kid like I lean towards girls I
had you know boy you know guy friends
growing up but it was like I was always
gonna pick the girls you know I always I
always loved I grew up with just with a
single mom I loved to be hugged yeah you
got to be around that so like when I was
learning how to sing I wanted to sing so
I could sing to girls hell yeah I'd be
onstage and like have a face tattoo and
like look at a girl in her eye and she
would remember me for the rest of her
life singing to her because one my voice
was great but I looked like how it
looked like like I'm this tatted dude
and I'm look like you're gonna remember
my face like that was my I knew I had a
look and I knew even before the tattoos
that I had a I had a face that I made
when I sung I really believed it even
when I didn't sing like that I knew I
had like a little bit of it you know in
my demeanor so I really stuck to that
you know I stuck to the package of
things like I'm melodic I can hold a
note let me keep doing it like I really
want to like sing for these guys I get
confident when I'm around girls like
that's the thing about me I get
confident in my art when I'm around
women a lot like if if I do a show and
there are a couple girls like like just
off to the side of it oh you will see me
twirl [ __ ] dance all night you know
especially if it's a girl that's like
like like I'm I really want to make her
proud there's a girl like for example
like I know like right now like I just I
I had these thoughts in my head and I
daydream of just like her being like at
the top and just me like performing
literally for this crowd but like she
knows like the certain songs I wrote
about her I want to perform the [ __ ] out
of those yeah cuz I'm just like yo like
I love to say
I like that like yeah as much as I like
to rap I love when the lights go dim and
the spotlight is on me and I really get
to show people like I can hold this note
I can do all this and I had never been
trained before in singing I just have it
and I think that a lot of kids that
again to bring it out of me I think a
lot of people that have natural talent
sometimes get discouraged if if they
don't go to like a school or if they
don't go to classes or if they're not
trained I mean a lot of singers that are
[ __ ] phenomenally talented but
they'll always just be like yeah but I'm
not trained so yo just don't you know
I'm gonna play this rough but just it's
like yo don't worry man I'm not trained
I still sing with my head voice
sometimes when I shouldn't like don't
worry you know what I mean and I mean
here's here's a thing too is you know I
see this a lot too with people who are
seeing and mmm I think this is a hard
thing for people with a hard pill for
people to swallow there are some people
out there who are great technical
singers right yeah technically you sound
great yeah but you're still missing
something
what attitude a soul a spirit I don't
know what it is but technically you're
hitting every [ __ ] no but I can't be
that I can't hear you for some reason
exactly no I'll do certain shows where
like I'll be on the bill but there will
be a singer on the bill too and they'll
be doing all these notes and everything
but you could see in the reaction of the
crowd it's like cool like nice I'm not a
technical singer it all go out there and
I'll sing certain notes and they'll be
like oh [ __ ] and again it's just from
the demeanor that I'll have there's
demeanor - singing - yes I'll need a
sing like you believe it a hundred so it
makes like a superstar a hundred percent
and I call those like the people who
sing really well it's like oh you're a
karaoke singer dude yes because you
could hit these notes I guess and I see
this a lot with like Korean and Filipino
people like there's a lot of karaoke
technically great singers at a Korean a
Filipino right but they don't understand
why it's like well how come I just not
really popping off it's like because you
don't have your style there's nothing to
you yeah like you're just a blank sheet
like yeah a blank sheets pretty right
but there's nothing to it yeah me I feel
like um and that you know now now I feel
like I can jump to even expressing this
point but
that's how I feel a lot of Asian artists
almost have like a chip on their
shoulder sometimes because technically
they're great because we see we as agen
people we've sat on the sidelines a lot
so we observe you know what I mean so
that's how we could get so technical
because we're never really subbed in
we're just yeah I was watching the game
so by the time we do get subbed in we're
like people listen to us you know us
meaning Asian people like Asian talents
sing or showcase something he'll be like
what I never knew you had that in you
mm-hmm you never knew cuz you didn't
give me a chance yes again this Asian
thing that you have lingering on in your
north american industry mind yeah but i
feel like i feel like there are a
handful of Asian artists that it's like
they're where they are right now right
now because they weren't as like
technical as some Asian artists do get
you know what I mean like I feel like
there are some Asian artists that are
just like overly technical to the point
where like a lot of the look is like too
clean you know what I mean and and a lot
of the music is almost too like no no
this isn't really you you're just
fitting into like making the song making
all these notes hit and like there's a
lot of vocalists Asian superstars
we're always known through game shows
and yeah you know what I mean yeah but
we've never I feel like and I don't want
to bring us down because some people can
be like oh but what about what about no
but at the same time but what about the
fact that we don't have a drake yeah we
don't have an Eminem or or a Madonna
than that you know I feel like I feel
like gaining your identity through our
originality again just comes from a lot
of I mean you know we haven't gotten
that person yet but it comes from a lot
of we this is time put in for one and
the platform mmm we don't have that
platform and I feel like once an Asian
artist comes and they have that like
look on their face like they know
they're gonna tear this [ __ ] up somebody
like
Bruno Mars yeah yeah yeah you know we
need more of that we need more that I
feel it Center Asian entertainers we
need more of that you know we could be
as technical as we can and do all this
but we need somebody that like will step
out there and put on a show
I don't think Asian people actually I
take that back because nowadays like you
know with you know shout out to Aquafina
to like yeah yeah you know people like
her like in other ways other than music
like we're now showing that we do this I
think we really need to show people we
do this and get out of the technicals of
clean music videos with like super pale
like nice skin and them you know you
don't always need to be that way yeah
like we can be Reggie - we can be angry
we can be sweaty - we can we can really
get down with this entertainment [ __ ]
yeah I really do feel that way I've met
so many Asian entertainers I'm like you
could be a [ __ ] superstar man we just
don't have the platform yeah but we
can't sit here and be like [ __ ] the but
not a blah blah blah and bring our bring
ourselves now no we're gonna have to
take that platform one there's others
groups like whatever like 88 rising
they're throwing their own cons
yeah there's this stuff which is very
important you know and that's like it's
kind of hard having this conversation
with some of my older friends right
where they were one they wanted to be
musicians you know and I listened to
them whether it was rap or whether
whether it was like hip hop or R&B and
one of the things that they were always
missing was their sound it was like yes
I think and it was hard for them to
understand what that meant and had a
conversation with one of my friends
where she wanted to be a saying she's
not a singer now she sounds amazing
like classically trained great right
film urato and everything it's just -
the [ __ ] tea right and we were
drinking and she goes you know like some
of these like YouTube kids where I see
some of these young people I think can't
seem like I do and I never really got to
pop up and I felt like I had the package
hey you know I had a couple of drinks
and as I get older I become a little
more honest and I just told it was like
you know what the difference was the
difference is between them it's like you
were sitting you're sitting at this bar
they're talking should have you're
talking [ __ ] about them but they're not
talking [ __ ] about you I was like cuz
your problem was is that you've always
focused on you being talented rather
than you really look exactly like do ya
like yeah yeah it's like that's where
your focus was I'm talented cool
whatever and funny enough that's where
my focus was for a lot of my life mm-hmm
I focused and again when I say I do
and I say certain things like that it's
because I love what I do oh well it's
not because I'm [ __ ] amazing at what
I do it's not that it's because I really
love this [ __ ] for what it is and I'll
go out it's like it's like a like a
basketball player if he's really good
sometimes like you'll just pass by like
if you guys are on the court he'll pass
yo give me a shot and he'll sink that
[ __ ] right in front of you
yeah because he loves this [ __ ] doesn't
want to be a [ __ ] you know a show-off
he's just yeah I love it let me take a
shot you know I mean like you know
you're always gonna want to take a shot
sometimes are you always gonna like play
around with that you know what I mean
again like when you're caught up in a
lot of yo I just want you know why isn't
the blah blah blah like you really do
get caught up in some like in
expectations you have expectations for
yourself but it's like if you're just a
little nice you to yourself and a little
nicer to what you do you can get to a
good place and I feel like again
circling back like when Asian
entertainers find that groove I feel
it's gonna be crazy
it's gonna be nuts you know so talented
yeah that's so technical and almost a
little again a little too technical
sometimes I feel like a lot of a a lot
of Asian stuff kind of gets a little too
clean
mmm in a sense that's why I like your
stuff like you swear you aren't afraid
to say a lot of what you [ __ ] need to
say and you are again like what we were
talking about before you're not afraid
to admit when you're wrong yeah and it
gives people like something to to really
watch dramatically even guys like Tim
you know pushing the envelope of like
not the conventional shy Asian actor you
know what the you know like it was too
like I didn't realize when I was doing
this stuff that I was doing anything
revolutionary you know because it was
when I used to do the vlogs where I used
to talking to a camera right now you
should just talk [ __ ] which is just how
everybody was where I grew up
yeah I didn't know that that was
something that unique that a lot of
other Asian kids didn't have growing up
because I lived in I lived in Sacramento
and that's where just how people exactly
I'll talk it is what it is yeah then you
know if I go somewhere else they're like
you know there was no other Asian kid
that was like you where I grew up and I
wanted to be around people like that
yeah oh really I had no idea cuz I'll
really me you know yeah I mean Asian
kids that tell me like I got out of my
shell cuz
your music no you know like a lot of and
again I noticed from from observing like
a lot of Asian kids sometimes they're
just like a little shunned or like they
get considered you know by by other you
know non-asians like as eight the Asians
yeah yeah
oh you're geeky and you blah blah blah
and it's like no I like hip-hop and I
like moshing and I like you know like I
like the skateboard and you know what I
love gangster [ __ ] like talking about
like but at the same time people were
just like hit with a preconception and
it's it's it's kind of affected a lot of
like younger Asian kids and again that
it's sometimes that trickles into the
music where some some Asian kids feel
like they need a look mm-hmm
you know what I mean like I need to look
like this you know cuz my favorite Asian
artists look like this and it's like you
could look like however you want yeah
you know what I mean like however you
want you really can look like whatever
you want bro like that's why I like for
me like even in this YouTube space like
I always hated a lot of those like
YouTube artists that were Asian that
always kind of hung onto the whole Asian
thing like oh because Asian people are
like this I'm Asian I'm Asian it's like
I'm to blame for that yeah I got a
certain point used it as a scapegoat hmm
it's like that thing at the shows you
know like you're not getting the good
reaction but you know there's Asian
people shout out all my Asian people
yeah we're back in it's like I don't
like that I didn't like that as a Chico
to you like I rep with this yeah I feel
like when I walk in I rep with this when
you read my bio it's Asian Canadian I
feel like I rep with that and I don't
need to announce it all the time to
people because again that's not my niche
I'm not I feel about it
artists almost make it their niche well
yeah because you want to be recognized
for your art you know at the end of the
day that's what needs to speak the most
and it's hard for people right even it's
hard for people to do that because that
they know they can get a certain
reaction for something every time
they're gonna go for that button and hit
that button you know and you know I like
when I was first doing stand-up I used
that [ __ ] all the time you know but then
after a while I got so sick of it I
started steering away from my culture
too much now I have to find that good
medium it's like way I am an Asian guy
yeah I can't talk about it but how can I
do it in a way where it's just I'm not
using it as a crutch
and I feel sometimes it is used as a
crutch mm-hmm like some dudes is like
some Asian comedians sometimes it's just
like [ __ ] okay I'm running out of
material you know what let me just
degrade myself you know like a billion
times and then and then sink into that
degrading and then it's like it's weird
because again a lot of those jokes do
get old a lot of those Asian
stereotypical jokes kind of get all that
at some point it's like okay my [ __ ] too
is like with Asian communist side you
could do those jokes but you had to put
your own spin and perspective on it yeah
it's like how can these people relate to
it you're just saying the same trope
everybody else's because we can rail you
know it's just like just put it related
to yourself like you know yeah you know
that's like that's why the people who
understand it's like damn Davy you
really don't like [ __ ] with a lot of
like Asian people in this space it's not
because I don't [ __ ] with them as a
person this is their content doesn't
speak to me growing up as a person so
yeah that's how I felt sometimes I felt
like certain things were a little too
clean for me like I even my look you
know when I was deep right I had a very
clean look but my life really like my
upbringing really wasn't like that well
we might be honest with yourself I
really think that's when your music
started to shine oh hell yeah I started
even getting tattoos and really like
this is what I are you you I love this
[ __ ] and I just every time I looked in
the mirror I was like oh you're getting
there
love you not even as an artist I would
just be like oh yeah
this is what you wanted to be yeah you
wanted all this ridiculous [ __ ] on he
wanted to stand out to you I didn't give
a [ __ ] about what anybody said that's
why I have certain things on my mom my
face like I was just like dude I I want
to be cool to me yeah I think yeah I
think I'm the coolest in the mirror now
I'm like yo I'm cool as an Asian kid I
used to not think that way and to me I
feel like you know there are certain
things you should have as a purpose yeah
I feel like one of my purposes is to
come in and show Asian kids that they
could be whatever they want yeah you
know I have certain Asian kids they're
like well what kind of hairstyle should
I rock I don't want to perm my hair do
anything but I just need to find you a
generic it's like do whatever you want
there are black kids that dye their hair
blond yeah and you're feeling a little
weird because you've grown up with
straight hair your whole life and you
don't want to go outside the box
you don't wanna get tattoos you don't
want to do to get out of this like
you've got to be a doctor thing all the
time and really like be yourself yeah
you can't as much as everybody in school
makes fun of you for being the Asian kid
or blah blah blah maybe you are good at
math or maybe you are academic academic
li forward but you smoke weed sometimes
I listen to [ __ ] wu-tang and you know
what I mean want to go mosh to some you
know [ __ ] at a concert it's like go do
that man
yeah and I go no I'll go to meet and
greets and kids are like yo I was in my
first mosh pit to your show no Asian
kids kids that look like me yeah that
feel that I look like them I'm on that
stage I have this platform hey cute
girls like him mm-hmm
yo [ __ ] this man it's cool to be me [ __ ]
that I'm me yeah you know and kids will
show me that like I'm proud to be Asian
because of because you are out there
making it look a certain way
you're just making you being Asian bu
and I want to be like that like I wanted
I want to make my own imprint of my own
[ __ ] and I think that's cool you know
especially looking at other cultures
like having a guy like Tyler the Creator
come out as a black man that likes what
he likes yeah he really he he really set
a standard to other black kids that were
like yo you could wear vans and go skate
and do certain things be yourself you
know I want to be that for Asian kids I
really want to come in and tell them you
know you could be yourself you don't
have to get the souped-up car to like be
part of your friend group and then you
don't got to do that you could be
yourself yeah an evolution of you always
like speaks in your music because you
know when I was like youryour music just
popped the Brandon Lee my playlist right
and I didn't realize your name went from
deep fried to Russell right and so when
I saw this Russell person posit yeah
this [ __ ] dudes go so I was listening
to it over and over and over and over
and I was like oh [ __ ]
like I think that's that kid deep fried
and I was like yo he's his music is
[ __ ] Banks banging right and I
started posting your stuff on my
Instagram and I didn't realize too that
other people didn't know that your name
changed either yeah because they're like
who was this guy I was like I was deep
fried and they're like that's deep right
they didn't know and so it was kind of
an interesting thing too when I said
when I started listening to your music
over and over and over and I had to go
through your old discography and I could
see that evolution change I was like
well it went from like this like we're a
clean type of music to like [ __ ] it
let's do something different and it was
different in my personal personal
opinion it was better because it sounded
like you were kind of falling into who
you were right it like your writing was
way better thank you yeah I mean it was
just different I was like oh this guy is
an artist you know what I mean thanks
man so I started posting your [ __ ] on
Instagram and Twitter and stuff thank
you for that too that's that's that has
always like I see the traffic and
everything and I'm really appreciative
of that great platform and like people
have really shown me love out of your
side so I mean I mean for me to like my
[ __ ] is it's like I don't know what this
is about me but it's like if there's
like somebody who's Asian that's [ __ ]
dope I'm gonna push them so [ __ ] hard
because yeah it does wonders for me as a
person too because it's like I want this
person to represent me as well yeah I
mean so when I saw this evolution of
your music I started watching these
clips of you perform just like you
practicing in that room I'm like oh he's
a performer like yeah and that's what do
you mean when you say like you do this I
understand what you mean because I've
seen you in every [ __ ] like outlet of
music being expressed and I was like oh
this kid does this for a living
this [ __ ] is him you know yeah again
like with with the d-pryde stuff I just
I was so much more than that and I was
willing to show people 100% even when I
switched this channel of the genius
brain right I didn't tell anybody which
I kind of regret because what kind of a
bad move because right when I did that
like a thousand people drop and they
resis cry because they're like oh I
didn't know that was you I was like like
400,000 subscribers in like two weeks
nothing oh sure I get him and then you
read some of the comments too like I
wanted here I wanted to come here for
the vlogs I didn't come here for this
[ __ ] I'm unsubscribing and I just you
know wrote back as I Amen thanks for
supporting up until now but go [ __ ]
yourself yeah you know we just kind of
moved on from there but now I've gained
a different following and when I found
out especially about people who follow
me what I really appreciate is that when
I first started out my demographic was
ages from like 8 to like [ __ ] 18 my
demographic below the age of 18 now is
2% so that means all these people that
stayed they grew up with me then I stir
now they're an adult I relate to that a
lot and it's nice it's like oh [ __ ] you
didn't leave
like how did you not leave in ten years
that's like watching friends from every
[ __ ] season all the way through and
you have been with me since day one and
that blows my mind yeah that's why I
think I have like some good stripes in
this [ __ ] like when when the [ __ ] really
gets to where it is like people can't
really question me like oh like one the
industry plant thing like nobody will
ever have to say that because I've been
in this [ __ ] for 12 years [ __ ] you um on
top of that just like I don't know I
just feel like I I I had enough of
evolution to really show people like
okay like I'm here I'm here
I deserve this yeah you know and that's
why I like again like it's circling back
you know I I find beauty in those deep
ride times I really do I feel I feel
great with them but I've laid them to
rest I feel like a lot of people haven't
and that's okay like cool those I can't
speak for a kid who's prom song or
homecoming song was one of my deep-fried
songs and that's what he'll remember for
the rest of his life so I don't work for
people to forget d-pryde I work so
people can understand and live with that
but also know that like all that music
cause like for me too uh I love Kanye
right I loved him right but then his
last stuff I didn't really like but
doesn't mean i'ma stop listen to his old
yeah yeah you know like college dropout
is very [ __ ] important to me yeah me
graduation very [ __ ] important 8:08
all that [ __ ] is super important to me
and I'll still listen to that [ __ ] I
mean and and one thing I've always
appreciated about Kanye tube was that
nobody was ever allowed to put him into
a box he didn't allow it yeah you can't
tell me to make college dropout again
I'm not college dropout was dim from
graduation graduation was therefore made
away snipers it was all different and
funny you say that like circling back to
even like the YouTube thing I didn't
want like I hope like other artists can
can listen to me when I say this but
like those boxes of being like it you
know people will tell you gain exposure
by doing covers or gain exposure by this
but like don't don't get comfortable
with that yeah like really really create
things
like really cuz you'll always be put
into a box if like you take one thing
and you run with it a little too hard I
think a lot of people run with it like
certain things a little too hard like
creative so they'll see what makes them
money the most and they'll just go hard
with that but sometimes you run those
ideas out and sometimes mentally you run
that out and then it doesn't get fun
anymore yeah and also yeah they die out
real fast yeah that's why you saw I
[ __ ] David Choi's a friend of ours
you know and David Choi I love the fact
that he was always pushing original
music cuz I arguably loved his original
music more than his covers and that was
that was something that I don't think a
lot of people wanted to do at the time
and David was a is a riot phenomenal
originals - yeah you know and I was like
did I make it last all afternoon was
like an incredibly written song his
writing is [ __ ] amazing ratably
written so yeah yeah he's one of my
favorite writers like like in that time
like he was influencing me a lot writing
was and I feel like he doesn't get his
credit so shout out David Choi yeah for
sure there's some some other arts too
it's like I listened to their covers I
was like this is dope and I started
their original music I'm like damn
there's some trash yeah like why didn't
you develop this part and that kind of
sucks for me too cuz I'll always like
their voice yeah you know or you know
whatever that they're doing but then
it's like when I hear them they're the
original music I'm like ah you're not
there yet man yeah like some people put
themselves in a box so yeah putting
limits to themselves right mm-hmm and
again it's like I got the niche of the
covers this is great and then they
concentrate on that so much creatively
that it's like this this that then the I
guess way in to nurture their mind and
make original stuff and train themselves
like kind of gets away and then you're
chasing momentum like a viral moment
also because that route is harder and
when they kind of reached that point
where they have to think for themselves
it frustrates them and that's why a lot
of like YouTube singers too that I was
around at a certain point like died out
because I took the route in which I
didn't want to take certain bookings
that were like very YouTube and like
only do these covers Asian creator
catered the bags were incredible mm-hmm
mind you like incredible bags but I'm
looking at that as like cool I can make
this right now and run off my deep
radness and my asian-ness and my this
ina third but like these are not things
that support my brand is an original and
and and just like creative entity like
it's going backwards for you yeah it's
almost like I'm just putting my again
I'm putting myself in a box so like
those certain artists I saw that they
kept running with the covers thing and
doing all those nice shows and
everything and then it started dying out
mmm
and I look at my career now and I see
that I've made at least like a good
little core base that accepts me for
certain things and when I do put like a
cover something out they're like holy
[ __ ] he's back
yeah I'm like cool I've made it a rare
thing now made it a thing where it's not
expected out of me so now it gets so
much more love which is I'm able to come
back to this and revisit it because
people say I'm an OG and and all that
other stuff it's just like yo like I
know how to tastefully space things out
you know I don't get caught in the hype
because I genuinely believe your
originals are way better than your
covers like your originals are way
better than your [ __ ] clothes man
yeah I prayed myself on that a lot and I
think um again like I have big plans for
like my songwriting ability like I want
to write for Beyonce but I want to write
not on my own terms but I just don't
want to be in a writing camp I want to
give a song to Beyonce that I feel like
Beyonce would really like that's done
that's how I feel I feel like I'm
confident enough to do that and I feel
like a lot of this stuff is a lot of my
new stuff is truth bearing you know what
I mean and I feel like if I can't if I
can't tell the truth now I can't write
it so it's like whenever I do come out
with something and if I did write it and
if I did come out you're gonna feel it
each time you're really gonna be like oh
[ __ ]
he like he felt these emotions like I'll
play you some stuff after this you're
really gonna like see like I just took
time now I took a lot of time to like
really make music I like people will
love but also that I love and especially
with this new album and all like I mean
I'm out here
kind of trying to promote it but you
know my new project is like it's like
very you know I don't want to say
coming-of-age but it's a reconnection of
like ones
it's called boy lonely and it's like
it's it's a good amount of songs short
and sweet but halfway through it starts
off very it starts off boyish you know
[ __ ] [ __ ] get money smoke weed I'm
this guy hell yeah I'm a rapper I live a
rapper life don't got a snapchat about
it I put it all on wax and I really do
that's how I live my life I don't like
when I go out or when I do crazy rappers
[ __ ] I just never recorded anymore
cuz I feel like I could just go home and
say it all and then when I hear these
songs I live in them yeah you know what
I mean so I usually like if I document
stuff I document the most regular
everything because I really want people
to see that I'm a regular [ __ ] person
yeah and you can just get like the real
rapper [ __ ] from the record so that's
when I put it all on wax even if I don't
like somebody and that's the thing too
about the album there are people that
I'm going at like I'm coming up that's
time I [ __ ] love that [ __ ] yeah I
missed that [ __ ] about hip hop dude I
feel like hip hop is one of those spaces
where you can truly say [ __ ] you to
somebody and it should still be okay
yeah and it was the weird space to where
like gonna I think like that social
media phase they're like well why can't
these rappers just get along cuz it's
[ __ ] my hip-hop dude shut the [ __ ] up
and a lot of people just take it a
little too crazy ya think that they
don't know they're like behind the
scenes that's all music yeah it's just
muted a little too crazy it's music
that's what it is that's what a pop like
started in man like dude like some of my
[ __ ] favorite tracks are [ __ ] hate
tracks do they feel good for some reason
yeah it's like the intro of my album is
like a hate track yeah kind of it's very
arrogant and I start it with arrogance
so I wanted to start the the album with
some arrogance and some like bravado but
then at a certain point in time and the
album switched to insecurity and like
that's the lonely part so boy with this
like look to people you know almost like
this is me yeah and then like lonely
where like I'm finally alone and I could
be like oh [ __ ] okay I
I say all this stuff but I'm actually
like huh
like there's [ __ ] going on you know
that's what I'm saying that's dope yeah
and I think I think that's a lot of
rappers and I think I want to be one of
those rappers to really express like
yeah I could be confident sometimes but
I can't break down but I'm able to bring
myself up and almost use my ego as a
positive crush at crotch you know to
bring myself back up with my ego and be
like yo I am good man like [ __ ] I'm
insecure like [ __ ] you know on the album
I rap about you know being at an age
where people are getting married now you
know yeah I don't take that as an
insecurity because I know that I just
love what I do and I'm working towards
towards something great and I want other
people that are 26 to hear that and be
like you know what I'm not married at 26
like Johnny down the block I don't have
a house like yeah will you call really
nobody's married at 26 man yeah people
are married at 35 36 years with people
my age like they get scared of that and
they get held to an expectation all
right so we're like traditional parents
too right like oh why aren't you married
yet that's crazy
la nobody's married at that age you
married at 26 you're [ __ ] stupid 26
like I can't even imagine married I
moved to LA when I was 25 20 more so
like even the thought of married at 26
baby [ __ ] my pants yeah I'm not even
just like at the fact where people have
expectations for themselves at 20 mm you
know like I wrote a song where like I
talked about like how I have those
expectations - as a rapper
but at the end of the day as much as I
don't have my house that I'm paying for
in financing and this I know third about
growing up things that I'm supposed to
be doing I'm working towards something
great and I'm gonna be something great
well and I am something great you know
and I feel like a lot of other people
should feel that way sometimes when they
get into their insecure moments I feel
like your life now though honestly it's
like everything's a cherry on top
because I mean you if you look at from
like the scope of things right like I
don't I guess from my perspective in
terms of like music and what people
wanted out of music you actually already
had that so now it's just you're just
doing it out of love yeah right cuz I
mean what do you technically if just on
paper what do you need to prove exact
all those boxes now is just like I'm
living this just because I enjoy it oh
yeah yeah
you know I want to do arenas and [ __ ]
you know I have I have a final my final
daydream in my head is I'm no I know I'm
gonna be the one of the biggest artists
in the world I'm gonna be in history
books I know that for a fact
and like in my head I really don't care
about the club anymore mm-hmm I could
get drunk anywhere really shout out to
the club like that's where you gotta go
sometimes in to really catch a vibe
that's cool I respect that
but when I look at my motivations to do
this like I'm good with the hot girl
[ __ ] like I I've had sex yeah thing
about it it's cool yeah I'm much more of
an intimate guy anyway so I can't really
go out there and like [ __ ] a billion
girls and you know what I mean like and
spend my money on it I don't do drugs I
don't do coke and [ __ ] so I don't care
about chains like I don't like you know
I mean because some kids like have less
than me and like I have like eight
[ __ ] gold chains on and it's like I
gotta sell a dude like I know a lot of
people here too that aren't in this
space and they go and I see what they're
riding in I see like they're [ __ ]
they got a rolly they got a [ __ ] yeah
I'm like bro I know how much you make
cuz I'm in your industry you should not
have that yeah weird misguided
perception you know that you have to be
a certain way to be an artist and none
of that really I don't really get amused
off any of that what I'm really amused
off of is selling a [ __ ] show out and
seeing people and then again you look
and you see like you're like five girls
that like yeah you're cute from your
from this town or like you know what I
mean the one girl you want to make proud
you know what I mean and just doing that
you know what I mean like singing for
this crowd and singing for them like
that's the bare minimum it's like I want
to be in green rooms I want to I want to
wake up in my tour bus and I want to I
want to like wake up to a new day of
having to brush my teeth in a [ __ ]
McDonald's bathroom yeah that's what I
like I like the discomfort of that
because I'm somewhere where man if I
wasn't doing this I I really would
probably kill myself you know and that's
the worst that's the weird beautiful
part about it you know at times where I
actually would have offed myself I was
off making music and doing this so
that's how I know I'm really made for it
you know I really love it and yeah you
could take a
way all this [ __ ] from it I still like
the money like the money is great let
this I'm not gonna be like her before
wasn't it no like I do it for a job too
but thankfully I make what I make with
it you know what I mean and I'm able to
take that and I throw it right back in
my career because I know I'm gonna make
it I know I'm gonna be the biggest
[ __ ] thing ever so [ __ ] it if if this
is gonna cost this much I'll rather do
this whatever that could be a bottom six
to impress the chick that could be you
know some ace but like [ __ ] the look I
am the look I am me people think that
you need to be a certain I need to be
seen out you know I need to be known to
any artist you don't need to be seen
anywhere the party's gonna always be
there
well the daughters of Isis will be there
the weed is always gonna be there the
drinks will always be there the girls
watch it's always gonna be there what
won't be there is your motivation and
love for it all if you keep [ __ ]
sinking yourself into that [ __ ] yeah
sink yourself into yourself and it's
selfish as that sounds
love yourself be sunken into your love
and your the [ __ ] stuff you make man
because you're really gonna see that
like as much as you love yourself and
you're gonna love everything around you
you know that's being lovely like you
got to stay with a lot of love for [ __ ]
yeah you know um what are you what are
you droppin the album when is this
coming out because I'm I'm announcing
the date Friday oh you'll be fine
February 15th tight and it said it's the
day my mom like it's my mom's birthday
so I feel like it's her birthday gift
and I really feel like you know on that
day I'm normally sad but that album is
gonna be out that day and she's gonna be
with me so I feel like it's a it's a
good time to put it out of course top of
the year too and I do feel like you know
it's a new start for me a lot of it
sounds a little more mature a little
more things that older people can play
and the younger people can find bounce
in mm-hmm and again it's it's that
reconnection story if you listen to
songs in the first part I say certain
things and that contradict them yeah
well purpose later on the album and have
certain songs like there's a song called
sucker and I and I talked about I talked
about you know being like a [ __ ] buddy
to somebody and you're running this
thing but they keep on telling you I
don't want to settle for less so bla bla
bla they keep they keep you know telling
you these sweet things like about like
what they're gonna do and why they're
single and why they're doing this and
why they're taking time and you really
think they're self building and then
they'd settle for somebody else because
they're running on a clock yeah and
you're they're like stop doing that
don't just get with somebody because no
have fun if you want to have fun have
fun you're gonna end up like cheating on
this dude and [ __ ] hurting him and
getting into a toxic thing because
you're not all the way in it you know
why be into something because you want
to have it title with somebody because
you're getting older like that's stupid
you know but at the end of the day I'm
just a sucker for girls that that need
guidance everything so that's what the
song is about you know and and I and
again like that speaks to a lot of dudes
I want to have fun sometimes and and and
they catch feelings or something you
know what I mean and and that's you like
you laying that [ __ ] down like catching
feelings like what the [ __ ] is that no
like we're humans we're going to feel
emotions sometimes you know what I mean
especially like if you have it bond with
somebody you just [ __ ] sometimes like no
you're gonna you're gonna see them as
somebody that's important sometimes you
know but it's like you want to see them
in better situations and getting with
some [ __ ] guy that it's like you
don't really have anything in common
with him you just chasing a clock yeah
are you all a being with some I mean I
know you're climbing with Tim yeah
that's on a separate song though I have
a single with him but there's no
features on this oh yeah it's all me
that's like some Jay Cole [ __ ] yeah and
I feel like they're little every album I
do actually mix it into a world every
album is a world in a universe and it's
like the boy lonely universe so you hear
little I have little sound bites and
little inserts in the song actually from
artists that from my city and everything
to really showcase that and a lot of it
is very it's very homegrown you could
listen to it and be like this there
wasn't eight people in the studio making
this
it's very like this is how I felt you
have a one main producer you work with a
message yeah his name's K beets and
there's another producer I have on his
name's Rancher and he was like a young
kid that like so talented but he's just
be around like smoking weed with us and
chillin and he played beats one day and
I was like yo like [ __ ] with you bro
like you we're gonna get one in don't
worry and it was like a couple months in
and he's actually part of like another I
have another group um because I do feel
like you know I sing and I rap but I
have a certain Lane and myself but I
also like the rage stuff mm-hmm
and very high energy music but I feel
like if I brought that in I confused a
little it got confused my main fans so I
have like a side group called nightmare
and he's like a third of that group he's
a producer and it's like a rage group
like it's crazy I'll play you some stuff
too like it's very rage core but it's my
way to get that off yeah cuz I'm also a
very like angry guy in a sense I make
like a lot of angry music but I don't
want to of course muddy the water of my
certain projects and bring in an element
that's a little almost to crunch for a
certain audience so but I still want to
get that off I feel like if I'm if I
like that stuff I should make it so yeah
he's part of my group and I had him do
like half this album too so it's almost
like I also have to put trust into
another in-house person and thankfully
you know Kay beats - he was like open
you know for the collaboration and he
mixed the entire album - regardless if
he only did half of it which is love
like that's love like he really loves me
like that he'll he'll mix the entire
project because he believes in it you
know and that's hard to find though
that's really hard to find somebody like
god dude five finding someone who could
mix your [ __ ] is the most difficult
thing on earth and the thing is I mix my
[ __ ] too so I feel the fact that I gave
somebody more trust that's pretty crazy
you make [ __ ] - yeah I do everything
like I edit all my videos i I like cut
all the vocals and make sure they're all
in place like but you know how rare that
is the right like people don't do that
like do not that the camp its empower
like getting it to my head too much yeah
so as much as it's a great thing I also
know that I do this because I'm
self-sufficient and I love it so like no
nice it's the best thing it's like I
like that because as an artist he gives
you power I don't have to wait for you
it's nice to have you around but if
you're not here if you die tomorrow I
can still get this done yeah like I'm
not dependent on certain people so
that's a good thing
I just like taking my tools though and
like using them in in certain places
like I don't like I knew that a certain
point in time editing my own stuff and
like mixing all my own stuff kind of got
to my head so I didn't I used to not
listen to people because I felt like I
knew everything and it wasn't until as
of recently like doing albums like I
haven't called lovely and there was a
lot of collaboration on that album and
that taught me the experience to stop
[ __ ] being a know-it-all sometimes
and actually listen to people that
actually have my best interest musically
that will tell me certain things and not
but in like this is my idea and it
should be like this more so like even
it's like therapy like they don't really
tell you what to do they give you the
option yeah and I think that that's the
best way to put an input give people the
option don't force people give people
the option yo you could go this way you
know what I mean if you really want that
if that's just working with the minds of
people I don't like to pressure people
that's pretty awesome man cuz like even
with me like I remember trying to music
I was like let me see if I can learn how
to record my I can't do this this is do
i [ __ ] this again like man like I hate
to repeat it but I lot of things were
from being shunned hmm no I couldn't go
to studios yeah and nobody would get me
studio time man I learned to do it
myself that was the biggest advice I was
giving to a couple of my youtube friends
were doing music and they just kind of I
look at them I go what a [ __ ] waste
you know and the reason why is because
they just chose they explicitly chose
not to hone their craft they chose not
to learn things in an age where knowing
how to do things yourself is very
important yeah because you don't because
before that prior to this if you were a
artist and you were signed to a [ __ ]
label you just did whatever label told
you to do you know why because you
didn't have a mic you didn't have you
didn't have any of that [ __ ] dude you
didn't buy your own preamps you couldn't
buy any of this yeah it was so
inaccessible but now that it is they
just always waited on other people and
they kind of died off it's like that was
your problem yeah you had enough clear
to how a lot of artists are like
incredibly informative and they're able
to absorb so much and like do things but
then they get to like this certain point
in their life we're like partying is a
little more like important or like video
games and like certain things are
important but they have like that side
of their career where they're still
relying on an engineer for certain
things and they're still relying on
certain it's like all that time you're
taking for your vices you could
literally take to sit down and learn Pro
Tools for a night yeah and and and even
if you're not a pro understand from an
engineer's perspective how it's like to
record you and see how they how you can
work with other engineer oh that's what
I did with that's why I learn how to use
premier and do my own videos down yeah
that's the best thing because then you
just start seeing the art of making
videos is not as easy as you think and
then you can communicate with you a lot
like the biggest thing right it's
because before you could just look at
something egg can you kind of do this
instead now yeah now you know exactly
what to tell him to do yeah like I was
talking to you earlier about my friend
Logan and like he's a video guy and like
how we both get along is like I do the
video stuff too and I'm able to
communicate with him like what I want
with him understanding like how possible
it is with my brain and when I how I do
talk to him about certain things and
like I'm able to break down lingo with
him and technical lingo with him that
will resonate in his head to know like
okay he does a video stuff so I can
listen to him rather than like an you
know an artist will go up to a guy you
all want to fly in the video right yeah
it's like no you got to understand how
video works like it's not that easy to
just fly you know like I'll bring very
possible ideas to Logan that are still
outrageous and like funny and out of
control but it's like they're possible
examine and it's because I put myself in
his shoes and I'm like and I've sat
beside the can like I said it on other
rapper sets and I direct like with like
my group back home my friend collective
like they do videos for other people
they're like a video production coming
so I am always surrounded by
behind-the-scenes people so that's how I
kind of know how to work with people
because I don't really play the star all
the time I get my hands dirty I like to
get my hands dirty you need to go for
sure you need to go into the field
sometimes and actually play in the mud
well that's their art of lying and
knowing your craft they just it always
helps all the [ __ ] time it's like
it's like when I see people who have an
opinion about certain stuff and they
haven't done it themselves I see that a
lot in like for example like like mixed
martial arts right
like they always have a comment about
some fighter doing some [ __ ] and but
it's like if you've never been there
before you actually don't you can't say
you can't say anything I mean you could
say stuff as a fan but if you're trying
to come off as an expert that's when
that's what we have an issue yeah that's
also like something I'm trying to learn
to at this age I'm just trying to be
less of an expert just be more so like a
guy that just knows some [ __ ] yeah
because I'm not a guru and I don't like
walking into things like that and I feel
like the best life lessons I've ever
learned were from people that just like
kind of like we're just chilling and
told me some [ __ ] yeah
you know like some of my like best
lessons were from Mike like I saw a girl
not too long ago and she just told me so
many things but in this relaxed like
chill way and she wasn't taking herself
seriously and a lot of what she said
really resonated with me because I felt
like I wasn't being lectured yeah you
know like and I feel like that's like
I'm trying to get to that point Amen I
said I say three of my favorite words
strung together is this I don't know a
lot of people can't say that I don't
know like when somebody has trying to
get used to saying that it's it's the
most it's the most liberating thing that
you'll ever say because it allows you to
take a step back and not be in the front
of the bus all the time so it's just
like I love that [ __ ] because you know
when I talk about certain stuff if I'm
my biggest thing is like if it's an
opinion I'll say my [ __ ] opinion yeah
I said go into a topic worse about facts
facts right then I'll just go I don't
know because I don't know because it
requires me to have a certain amount of
knowledge about something right we've
been practicing something with all right
correct me if I'm wrong exactly like
that's like the best way to kind of go
about certain things and still express
your opinion with also giving somebody
the weigh-in tell you that you're wrong
and let them know that yes I'm down to
learn the right yeah and I could say
something like from my experience right
because because it's just an opinion
about my experience that you take it or
[ __ ] leave it the problem is it's
like sometimes when people don't know
things they just start bullshitting out
of their ass it's like that's not true
yeah just say you don't know well you
don't know you don't know and circling
back to like what we were talking about
in the beginning too is like the people
in my circle I felt like they didn't
know certain things and they were
telling me like they like you did and
then that's what [ __ ] a mine it
clouded
my perception as a young boy and a lot
of it's like y'all like I look at it's
like at the time too like I'd wanted to
be in relationships and I was a really
lonely kid
mind you I'm this kid from Brampton
Ontario that moved now to New York City
and it's like the city is bigger than me
I'm lonely [ __ ] my mom has cancer and I
just want to talk to a girl and it's
like everybody around me is like [ __ ]
these [ __ ] man like yo this work you
know what I'm saying like and then you
get a girl and it's like I'm happy with
a girl and they're like gay and it's
like [ __ ] dude yeah like you know what I
mean
I look at [ __ ] now and it's like those
people didn't really know they thought
they knew to tell a kid to always like
the message was they're like yo yeah
that you like these girls and everything
but yo you know the real mission you
have an advance and you have this deal
it's kind of pressuring you no don't go
off and waste your time man but it's
also at the same time if the kid is kind
of happy like leave him in it for a
second yeah like that's that's just them
kind of regurgitating advice from stuff
that they don't really know about
because they probably heard from
somebody else like exactly don't let
your artist like these girls will ruin
their [ __ ] life yeah but instead it
was it's like people forget that people
are people like a special artist you
really have to curate an artist in the
right way and when an artist doesn't
feel comfortable they don't feel they
don't feel like heard yeah [ __ ] them up
a lot didn't funny enough I used to be
that guy to tell other artists you know
don't get a girlfriend and don't blah
blah blah but then like I would just see
the look on their faces like [ __ ] yeah
like and it's like sometimes it's just
not like that I'm just speaking from a
place of bitterness yeah like I always
tell people to like if I ever say that
to somebody like I said like don't get
it open to a friend to a certain red
because we I've known him for years and
I know what he's like when he has a girl
it's like your whole you throw out your
whole career out the [ __ ] window and
then you just chase her around for hours
that's where I can see it because I've
had years of rapport with you I known
you for 19 years
so now that I've known you for 10 years
I've seen you [ __ ] up the same way with
13 girls now I could say hey your career
is going really well
try not to date for a little bit and
just wait
that part you know but when somebody is
young and you don't know them you don't
know you don't you haven't even had a
conversation with them like that about
how they feel is a little problematic
and I do feel like I was like that in
certain way I got run off on my chicken
just do dumb [ __ ] but again to justify
my actions it was like dude I'm [ __ ]
lonely in New York yeah I need somebody
yeah Oh like all my friends are [ __ ]
like by this time Instagram is out mmm
it's like you got a look at all your
friends back home grow up without you
yeah and who are you talking to like
everybody born in 86 yeah it's like yo
yeah I don't have anybody to relate to
all the problems I'm hearing are these
grown-ass problems like I wanted I want
to hear my friend talk about like yo I
couldn't [ __ ] this [ __ ] at a party I
got a little too drunk like I never
heard any of that stuff mm-hmm you know
what I mean like it was always a
professional grown environment with like
grown ass [ __ ] and like bougie dinners
and and again like these kids think that
that's the life it really [ __ ] isn't
yeah fun is the life you know and but
the thing is I don't regret those times
and I don't shun them out like again
those times made me who I was so as a 26
year old man when people kind of come up
to me with certain things of money and
yo I could take you to Nobu for our
meeting it's like that's cool bro it's
like I can get that myself yeah like you
know what I mean I like the management
teams that'll take out shopping and [ __ ]
just a [ __ ] butter you up it's like
you can't butter me up i butter myself
yeah it's like that's where I learned so
I can't all the way Shawn those times
cuz it's like that was the hardest part
about me going into like the whole
acting industry it was just a lot of
just like just this this talk I just
didn't grow up with right so like hey
man I saw you in this blah blah you're
so super talent it's like what are you
saying this for you don't know me yeah I
mean like just now just let's talk about
whatever we talked about or they would
try to meet up a certain place I don't
want to meet up at well let's go to this
like fancy Holly hey dude I used to
[ __ ] like I used to [ __ ] go into
the bathroom and like straight my jacket
out my [ __ ] going to the meeting and
like playing records and act like I was
like relaxed damn I wouldn't do that I
was right as the exact is anxiety for
that but again rightfully so I'm this
kid that grew up as a [ __ ] child
I mean I need to please everybody yeah
but like what was your experience I just
show up in flip-flops and socks and a
t-shirt in the shorts yes so and the
funny thing is like I didn't know that
that was a reason why I left a good
impression because I didn't know what
these things were and like I don't ever
do research on [ __ ] that I don't give a
[ __ ] about right so it's like yeah I
never gave a [ __ ] about acting I love
the art of acting but my mission was
never to be like you were you have this
dream of being this great musician I
didn't have that for acting I just want
to see if I could do it yeah and so like
when I was going into these meetings I
remember at these casting meetings and
then I wouldn't meet some of these
casting directors after their like David
oh you remember me it's like yeah you're
the only person I know they came to a
[ __ ] general meeting with flip-flops
and socks and a t-shirt and shorts I was
like well you told me to come casual and
I was like well typically when people
say casual don't dress up a little bit
but we like that about you though it
looked like you just were just there to
talk oh yeah I was just there to have a
conversation cuz I didn't know what was
going on like you guys saw something at
me yeah I know I don't know what it was
but I'm just here to talk so it was just
like in those type of situations like I
don't know if that was good or bad thing
it wasn't calculated but they thought it
was calculated I'm like these are
calculated moves like I can only be
myself and I always say like my
successes or everything I've done up to
down was like a fluke living you know
I'm just living I'm just like okay we'll
see if this works
and it has and it always and has always
been working out which I'm very very
[ __ ] grateful it's awesome which you
know I think it's always been rooted in
the fact that I never did stuff that I
didn't really want to do yeah and I've
never been able to do that that's why I
like when there was a lot of these like
YouTube challenges things started going
to pranks all this other stuff I just
could never do it yeah you could never
go with those emotions I was I feel like
music sometimes yeah you know like some
like people thought I did the face tap
thing to like be like a SoundCloud
rapper no like I literally just did this
because I didn't want to look like other
Asian artists yeah every Asian artist
was clean-cut no no well of course I
didn't do it for the artist thing first
I actually did it cuz you won yeah top
priority I did it cuz I want some face
tats like it was yeah but like second
thought like career-wise if we're if we
really want to bring it there like no
other person looks like me I'm the Asian
realm so like I'm good with that
yeah you know what I mean like and on
top of that I'm come quite I'm very
self-aware I'm quite articulate my eye I
know them
aurélie I'm great and I don't speak like
a lot of artists and don't carry myself
like a lot of artists so the tattoo
thing I feel is almost like my I wore my
scars on myself you know I have a little
edge to myself because I actually been
through the [ __ ] that I say I've been
through so I don't like I didn't ever
think it was like you know I gotta be
gangster for people or like you know
what I mean like I need to be this on
the third I just did it because I wanted
to when you when you were kind of going
through soon as I remember like you were
you had like an Instagram post where you
know you were talking about like your
issues with like suicide and stuff what
was like going on through your head at
that time because I think for a lot of
people when they kind of look from the
outside looking in and they see an
artist who have who has what they want
yeah I can't really wrap their head
around like what I kept a lot of things
behind the scenes mm-hmm
I think I know which post you're talking
about too and at the time - I was like
beefing with a bunch of people for like
the stupidest [ __ ] reasons hmm they
still don't like me I don't care though
but it's like it was just stupid and I
was like what am I doing this for at a
certain point like and my thoughts of
suicide used to just come from very like
selfish lonely thoughts and which still
creeped my mind till this day and but
I'm able to ward them off thankfully I
think therapy helps with that but I did
feel and sometimes I do feel and I feel
a lot of people can relate it's like you
sometimes you feel like you want to die
for a day and just see what happens you
know hmm I feel like my impact was like
weird I feel I felt like if the if it
been but with all this [ __ ] work I'm
putting into rustle if I were to get
popped like I don't even mean to put
that in the air I don't want to put that
in the air but hypothetical situation I
get popped the news will just keep on
saying d-pryde and I was like I'm not
respected even - and it was just all
these over thought overdrawn thoughts of
me being exhausted every girl I was
talking to at the time - is like [ __ ]
the same girl you know what I mean it's
like I was going on repetitive dates and
I was you know I had a group of friends
that were like almost like all like just
following me rather than trying to like
help me out so it was like I
I had a collection of things that were
just bothering my mind and I think um
around the time I moved out of my old
house and moved into my own apartment
which was like last year December all
that changed like I didn't care about
anybody or anything that didn't service
me in a positive way so a lot of I
started even getting more in tune with
my depressive thoughts and started even
weaving those out mm-hmm you know now
I'm depressed over [ __ ] that matters
yeah and it hurts a little harder well
my priorities in check so if I'm ever in
an irrational situation I can just take
that's a great thing about being a
[ __ ] adult though it's like sometimes
when you're in high school and when
you're super young you're put into these
situations that you feel like it's it's
permanent like you have to be in here
it's like some kind of like social
reprimanding that'll happen like you're
in a group of friends where you don't
want it where you keep this friend
around who's super negative but you
don't want to say anything because the
group might feel weird so you say yeah
yeah I don't have that anymore and
you're an adult it's like you may not a
parent thank you he's the [ __ ] out you
have your choices yeah you have the
freedom of your choices like you can
literally say [ __ ] this person and dip
you know I'm at a point where I'm not in
like high school relationships with
girls anymore yeah like I can literally
just be like yo I don't give a [ __ ]
about this it's not [ __ ] servicing me
well I gotta go and it's harder when
you're younger but when you're an adult
that's why I love being an adult and
sometimes when I remember something I
was at a college was like a few years
back and this kid was like he's like hey
do you ever miss like being like like 20
like I'm 20 I feel like I'm free I was
like how much money you got your big
account I say what are you doing
tomorrow starting for a [ __ ] finals
I'm not doing that [ __ ] yeah it's like I
got guap I'm good
yeah I have a lady what do you got
people see all this like washed-up and I
don't like that I was like you're I'll
see I was like you're the most unsure
human being I've ever met in my life I
have certainty in my life and it's a
years to get to that point you are not
somebody I look forward to being at all
yeah dude it's so funny you said that
too cuz I get kids that like God to me
and talk to me like I failed sometimes
like so wild it's so cuz I was deep ride
once and it's like kids
like are like like I'll take the train
and people don't understand I take the
train by choice cuz like I lived in
Manhattan and like Wall Street
billionaires take the train like people
just I don't get it I'm like I take the
train cuz why the [ __ ] not
yeah and I'll like meet kids that'll
just be like like yo like do you ever
get mad that you didn't get to where you
want so I just started oh yeah what are
you talking about like Oh nah dude you
don't get it I do what the [ __ ] I want
yeah I'm able to go on this train cuz
I'm not as famous yet and I still enjoy
my luxury of being a normal person yeah
like you think that I am NOT happy
because actually if you look at this I'm
26 I got my own apartment with with
rapping I'm able to wake up and make my
own schedule I can take this train right
now and go right the [ __ ] home to my
home that I paid for and I consciously
take the train because I don't want car
payments for a car I don't need cuz I
get driven everywhere cuz I'm a rapper
yeah like yo I'm straight I'm dope it's
just other people they have their
insecurities in their heads so they
think that damn if I'm taking a trainer
if I'm just in public like that like
that meat doesn't mean that means I'm
not Papa that's like even from they push
it onto you and a narrative on to you
like you didn't but it's like yo I'm
happy doing what I want 100 grown and
I'm going to talk yeah I look at this
like for what it is that's why I like
for the for the longest time my guy
people didn't know but if you look at my
very first youtube videos everything I
did and I don't think is probably cuz
I'm a little bit of an [ __ ] too like
I did anything I could to go against
what everybody believed I should be yeah
like I mean it's like anything that you
think that you could tell me I have to
be I'm gonna do the exact opposite
every if you look at all my old videos I
think for like three four years I only
wore free clothes whether it was given
to me in a car or free clothes it was
like the ugliest [ __ ] t-shirts and it
was literally by choice and people
didn't get that either even recently to
like I went through this whole phase
where I was like you know what I grew up
really poor so I'm gonna buy everything
that I [ __ ] want and it didn't make
me happy
right it was dumb I was like yeah I
thought getting the the testing when I
first dropped or
I drop a hundred G's on that car I'm
like I'm gonna get this [ __ ] car I
got it
had it for a month I was like [ __ ] about
all these [ __ ] kicks I thought I
would really [ __ ] like it and I was
like I'm not even aware of it I'm just
having it just to say like [ __ ] you I
could afford this crazy I went through
the same thing tonight I went through
the same exact thing I got a rid of a
majority of that [ __ ] and then later on
what I found out too was like oh like I
just like experiences yeah I mean I like
doing stuff the way that I want to do it
you said that ties I went through
something recently like you know get
your first place in again like I was 24
25 yeah I mean like I'm a rapper so I'm
thinking like yo I've relived a rapper
life if I got my own place and called
some [ __ ] do you know and I'm not
gonna lie to you you know I've had a
couple rendezvous somes like that but it
wasn't ever as late as I thought it was
gonna be hmm and I stopped like that one
day it had to be like a month and a half
or something that I was like doing it on
I just stopped I'm like y'all have a sex
bro like like even before that just in
life like what am i proving you're not
wanted this place for what and then I
met somebody to not explain too much of
the situation because I want to leave
that and just the songs and everything
but she had she'd stayed over for a bit
and it gave me this [ __ ] different
perspective I was like oh [ __ ] like [ __ ]
waking up with somebody - this is sick
what yeah like this is great like I had
the cry when she left and everything I
was like wow my whole perception is
living alone and getting a place and
finally adulting was like freedom and
thinking that this I know but like no I
just
I made a home and my experience for
making this home is incredible and like
I thought I'd get an experience from
different girls every night and being
like a bachelor in love but I got
experience from a real life situation
where somebody actually cared about me
and came into my home yeah and treated
it with respect as much as I did it just
made me see things in a grown-up way and
I was like damn I'm grown up this is
sick like wow like life is life is
really not like some
time's the most material Vicey way I
think about it you know that's why again
like I related to my my final goals it's
like yeah I would love to be rich but I
want to be rich with my dad taking care
of yeah like I have plans of getting my
dad a specific house and I have plans of
putting my sister through a college and
letting her actually finish unlike me
and my brother and and just real life
goals for myself that all have to do
with making sure that everything that
got me there is taken care of
yeah and everything else is more so like
I have just goals of like traveling the
world I just want to travel the world
all traveling is amazing man yeah that's
what I want to do travelling is like one
of those things that I that I always
make it a plan to do it every year
because it's an experience yeah it's
like that that's the that's those values
that I was talking about where I choose
to spend my money where it matters right
so I spend it on traveling because no
matter how many times if you if I buy
something like this right this iPhone 11
whatever Promax or whatever right when
you first get it this cool is doing
great things that's great
a week later whatever one then whenever
the next iPhone comes out this thing is
like the value obsolete
your memories of when you travel in the
experience that you have with people
when you're there they never become
obsolete they get more intensified as
you continue to miss them and I was like
oh I'm gonna invest my time and money
into this because me grows with me it
never leaves that's like a thing to with
like club friends and like industry
friends like people think getting drunk
is like what the experience is when you
go out or like doing all this stuff but
you're doing it around like promoters
and like people that don't like do it
around your friends well you know do
certain things around your friends or
like go travel somewhere and be with
your friends like you know what I mean
like people will spend like four grand
on like bottles and [ __ ] and like oh and
I don't mean to get in anybody's pockets
but like you equate that to like
actually like going somewhere hot and
you know what I mean like where the
currency stretches a little more and you
can like dive into a [ __ ] like river
and [ __ ] and like being some blue ass
water it's like that's so much cool over
an experience and you and your friends
can go do that yeah and then go get
drunk there
yeah yeah those things that'll really
kind of bring you longevity and you know
I'm trying to work on now yeah it's I'm
not perfect well you're 26 man you
[ __ ] mad young do you yeah I think
you're getting there to that point man
and like like I said like it's just all
that stuff leads up to you becoming a
better person and you just start to
evolve and so like all the stuff that
you've had in your past is the reason
why your music is the way that it is now
is the reason why you you you have
perspective is because you went through
a lot of [ __ ] and I always say to the
people that I [ __ ] with most of the ones
who had the most [ __ ] up lives all my
closest people have the most [ __ ] up
lives crazy
and at the end of the day to like his
[ __ ] up his [ __ ] was for me I find so
much beauty in it like I wouldn't have
it any other way man yeah I'd be if it
wasn't for that we wouldn't have a
Russell you know that's that's yeah
that's the crazy part about it right
it's like [ __ ] if it wasn't for all
these x-amount experience how many times
I got [ __ ] over these times I try to
kill myself this time you know even like
you know the experience of like your mom
being taken away from you like these
type of things it's like only Russell
can could have handle it this way and
put it into the art this way yeah which
is kind of crazy when you think about it
right because it's this tragedy that
allows this beautiful art to come out
and I just don't like I find the best
comics the best directors the best
musicians have always had something
tragic happen to them and they didn't
able to kind of take what this terrible
thing and they turn into something
beautiful and that is where I really
appreciate art a lot it's like [ __ ]
that's what art does dude yeah you can't
really do that with a lot of things I
mean what what other medium do you know
that you can do that with like it's
insane yeah yeah it's a yeah I mean so
I'm happy I found music at such an early
age well you know I don't I really don't
know what I would have done like I mean
tracing back to like my cases of
depression and anxiety from like 15 you
know when I didn't understand those
feelings you know I didn't understand
that I was depressed I didn't understand
anything until I really started
listening to music and people that would
talk about it and how much that helped
me
and how much my creative way to like
really express my problems and put them
down help me yeah um and arts beautiful
that way there are kids that like I'm
not book-smart at all at all but more
out like mmm through art I found so many
things through morality and
self-awareness you know that I was able
to kind of look at my cell phone was
from a bird's-eye view using art no I
was able to reflect myself listen to
songs about my situation why do I relate
to this song so much why is you know
what I mean like almost being studious
of yourself through you know your
creations almost taking like like I take
songs that I've made back then and I
actually study my behavior in them mmm
you know especially like when we were
talking about my label situation like I
used to rap about them and like how much
I hated them and all this stuff and like
I listen to that stuff now and I'm like
wow dude you did not handle that right
but it's good it's like a log mmm you
know it's a little log that I can you
know ooh okay that happened but I'm
happy I had all those you know like I'm
happy I had something a creative outlet
or something to talk about these
situations whether I handled them right
wrong or not I had a way to get out you
know um that's why I see art it's a way
to get out sometimes without having to
fully run away you're just in it that's
awesome man you know we like music I'm
just in it I I write songs about the
craziest craziest [ __ ] and I'm just in
it you know like a girl I miss I'll
[ __ ] just a song about her bro like I
mean I've been listening to this like
why I'll play it for you again like I've
been listening to song like ten times a
day that's dope man and it's just
because like I could sit there and
[ __ ] be torn over not being with her
all the time and just be in my own
sadness but ice listen to that song and
all of it goes away it's like not you're
happy like you're gonna work hard so you
could like see her again or some [ __ ]
you know like you don't have to think
that way and happily again like music
has always given me that that sense of
security art you know gives people a
sense of security in a place where it's
like actually free where you can take
that like dive you know the trust dive
and like be cushioned by something
you know I think creation is that the
best cushion sometimes yeah because you
can be supported by the bed you make you
know what I mean like it's it's a good
life man being an artist and being able
to do what you love and have it be your
career at the same time because at that
point it just stops feeling like we're
using it as a good mental aid oh for
sure you know again like even actors
like they use acting as an escape yeah
you know from whatever they're going
whatever's going on in their house you
know in their household like they can
literally come on set and not be that
guy yeah you know or not be that girl
you just totally switch it over and and
you're this character now and you can
run away for a bit and almost relate
some of the things that you have to the
character which is why I will get
actresses and actors that that can cry
on camera so unbelievably well you know
because they're able to tap into
emotions and that's creative might be
active - I want to be I have plans for
it I actually have plans to want to be
like in certain indie movies and I want
to grab these duels I think you just
you're a very in tuned person so it's
like thank you that's like one of those
things that actors really need because I
see a lot of people who want to be
actors and like you don't even know what
the [ __ ] your feelings are dude like how
the [ __ ] order to get out of in order to
play another character you need to
really really be self-aware Oh hyper
self-aware man that's why that [ __ ]
movie that it was so hard cuz like I had
to sit there for like [ __ ] four
months and just do in this character I
should maybe lose my [ __ ] mind I
shave my head three months before the
role is there method acting and all that
yes I just sit there and and this
[ __ ] just simmer in that [ __ ] [ __ ]
made me lose my mind like it's so funny
too because like the character that I
was playing had a lot of like internal
angst it was like that that character
that it was like Asian kid who wants to
be a musician and he's just different
you know and he kind of grew up in a
very hood ass area and then people don't
expect he's certainly nice to in that
[ __ ] and then when I was on set I was
like this irritable human being and I
was like I'll [ __ ] this character's
[ __ ] me up you know I'm not an
irritable person like I'm usually really
happy and jolly it sucked in a little
too hard yeah and then like I got really
pissed on set I [ __ ] smash the chair
dolls I was like oh let's take a step
back I'm like there's not very much like
well you know the film came out great
but [ __ ] man it's kind of hard when you
have to just go through these negative
thoughts all the time constantly yeah
over and over I sure can get you there -
OH
you know what I mean pressure can really
make you do your job for the wrong
reasons you know that's why I just try
to keep myself less pressured with
things well it's always good to kind of
just give yourself the floor when you're
creative to like you know what you I
have the floor to do whatever I want you
know I mean before we sign out I mean
okay so the album's coming out February
15th right what else should people be
looking forward to other than the rest
of my career um I have a lot of thing I
want to showcase a lot of myself this
year so I have after this wrap project I
really wanted to I really wanted to like
really get to people in a way where like
they know that I can do more but this is
what I'll give them right now I like to
pace everything out I don't like to give
everything at once that's not how I am
as a human being with anything
I give things to you like they're
already complete but that's just because
I'm good and I know how to make things
that sound complete but I'm always gonna
come equality yeah and I want to come
out with another arm B project but do
arm B my way everything's gonna be my
way I really want to show people that I
can do things my way this year so that
way a little more videos and video
production I really want to jump on
making my merch line the like you know a
great I really do feel like I make some
fun looking clothes and I just want to
keep that up and keep like the good work
up and I really look forward to all that
stuff because funny enough I'm getting
more eyes on me now than I've ever had
in my career so there's no one or like
you there's no I never know where this
is gonna take me so I'm just playing it
as it goes in a good way like I don't
even know it's gonna be here you know so
it's uh I made it all works out at the
Edmond yeah I have a lot of good things
planned so I'm just you know as big as
they are to me I just want to make sure
that they're a little paced out and good
and I wanna I definitely want to walk
through with it with my audience instead
of here having a billion expectations ya
know I'm gonna walk you through this I'm
a rapper here's some singing stuff
here's some acting stuff here's some
clothes I'm just gonna show you guys
like this is everything that I do and I
don't have to brag about it I don't have
to come up here and you know
[ __ ] disability in people about it I
don't have to do anything I'm gonna do
my best
a minute I think you're on the right
track man yeah that's what I got like
literally my best coming up but boy
lonely is yeah like for real I really am
sold to this album as a person and I
feel like if anybody's gonna listen to a
project that should like it that wants
to get to know me know me definitely
listen to that one um and I feel like
it'll kick off a lot of good feelings
about me and then you'll want to retrack
and see things yeah and yeah I just I
have the cent thing with Tim coming up
soon
it's a nice little single I don't like
he needed yeah do you like it yeah so
Tim Tim hit me up and he was like hey
what do you think about this isn't that
he was asking me for a couple of pinions
on the stuff that was catches [ __ ] yeah
I wanted to give Tim a song because I
sent him a song before and it was very
like nation like none stood being goofy
on the song but like perverted lines and
[ __ ] yeah but I was like man I I really
feel like you should have a hit they're
like you're that kind of me like you're
that guy to like be on record like fun
cool records like this and like talk
like how you do on every record yeah I
want to hear you be like this kind of in
my head that's how like I really
envisioned Tim to be on a record like
yeah have a hit and like beat him on it
and that's exactly what he did he's like
Tim on it yes I feel like I complimented
it like in my way but it is his single
and I just like it with his like that
his voice sounds cool on it yeah and I
like Tim's stuff so I'm happy that I'm
at least I have a song with Tim that's
like a little more serious yeah in a way
so that's coming up too and a lot more
I'm trying to work with more artists and
do some features and [ __ ] like I really
want to jump on more features this year
I think I have so many like incomplete
songs - it's just I'm waiting for the
right artist to be like yo you want like
Iraq's just gonna happen man yeah well
man I mean we've been talking for a good
two and a half hours I think Jesus I
think you beat the record in the longest
podcast I've ever done anything I don't
even know that was two and a half hours
actually went by like that yeah that's
just crazy a lot of me saying like a lot
but it's cool
more than I have it is what it is and
you know I'm yeah of course before we
sign out I just want to say thank you
because I you know for a long time I
just I tried to keep away from
interviews and I tried to keep away from
being on camera because I thought that I
was annoying in a sense I thought that I
I didn't fully know myself yet I feel
and III kind of know myself now and I'm
able to hop on camera and talk to people
but I want to talk to the right people
and I feel like you were one of the
right people that I wanted to be in a
room and spend two hours with so I think
I appreciate it man like I said I miss
luck in podcast and this podcast is just
about opening up like I told you man we
don't have I don't have any preconceived
topics in my head I always let people
talk out and feel out what they want to
talk about right just cuz I think people
are just interesting in and of itself
like I don't need to guide the
conversation anywhere yeah you know like
it just if you have thoughts in any ways
if you are an artist I'm pretty sure
there's a thousand thoughts in your head
and there's things that I just want to
know about you personally right yeah
and it always works out that way too and
I think that's why I love doing this
podcast because I don't have an agenda
to make somebody angry happy cry I'm not
doing things for clear views it's just
this is a conversation I would have had
with you either way
yeah and conversations like this last
for sure you know what I mean like it's
always it's always good to to actually
sit down and have nothing to talk about
everything to talk about I love it is
the best part of that like [ __ ] like
this so thanks man
yeah Mary she helped you out again dude
just I can't wait till after yup and
then we see and then when you [ __ ]
really big up there I'm gonna call you
up and you ignore me I'm like this tight
oh no I won't do that there's money
enough thing is I'd like to revisit this
conversation my joke - I always tell my
friends like if I see them on the
streets and I'm like you know if I say
what's up to you and you [ __ ]
recognize me I was like you're not
famous enough yet dude get the [ __ ] out
of my face I love the gag and send foods
were like this the gag of you not being
the famous one is a gag dude keep doing
that [ __ ] is so funny was shoot right
and then we're shooting and people come
with like Davey K get fall I was like no
that's not the big get the [ __ ] out of
the video
don't come up to me right now dude
the video it's so good and again like
again before we sign off I just want to
give you your flowers for being again
like an Asian entertainer that is fully
himself and take the flack I've
witnessed you take the flack for it and
I've also witnessed you win for it and
it's just a great beautiful thing to see
you make what you want talk like how you
want like you your demeanor has never
changed it's so cool even ever since
your Korean Jesus like skit on
dumbfounded zone you've always just been
the same guy so you know from me to you
of course like keep it that way because
that's why I [ __ ] with you thanks man
it's not I can't change if I change I
kill myself that's basically about it
yeah
hey you could catch us on any audio
platform Spotify I to stitchers if you
want to leave comments below show a lot
of love album drops February 15th that's
boy boy lonely if you don't [ __ ] with
this music you don't [ __ ] with me period
in the story I would see y'all next time
dang